This is Jocko podcast number 17 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Yeah,
it's been 10 years since April 2nd,
2006 10 years since those of us in fourth platoon huddled around the radio
outside of an Iraqi army post near Camp Ramadi,
trying to make sense of the confused and uncertain radio traffic of the exos
calm and from voice from the coc trying to determine what truck had been hit and
who was missing
10 years since we drove the road back towards the Gulf center with fear in our
minds and hate in our hearts knowing we had lost close friends,
but not yet sure of the names.
Yeah,
10 years since I met my platoon commander on the dark and steps of the Gov
Center as he came down from the COC and confirmed which truck it had been and
when I pressed for who was gone,
he simply said all of them.
We hadn't yet learned that one guy who was a fucking hard ass who wasn't going
to let death take another marine that day and who's recovery has been an
inspiration to all those men who know him.
10 years since I did my best to pass the word to my team with steadfastness,
but repeating all of them,
revealing me for the 20 year one year old,
I was through the tiers.
I was trying to hold back
10 years of trying to figure out what their sacrifice meant of shifting views on
what it was.
All four in the end.
That is something that is still a struggle,
but I've found solace and purpose in these facts.
Staff Sergeant Eric Macintosh,
Corporal Scott Procopio,
Lance Corporal Kuhn,
young Kim and hospital men.
Giovanni Pedea were men who chose to be part of something bigger than
themselves.
Men who chose to enter a profession of crushingly hard work,
sacrifice and danger,
all for the simple purpose of protecting the men around them.
Staff Sergeant Mac was the epitome of a fighting marine,
a stud who exuded proficiency and professionalism while also being humorous and
approachable.
Procopio is without a doubt,
one of the finest men I've ever had the fortune of meeting a beast of a marine
who drove all around him with his and good nature.
While we were peers,
I looked up to him and his natural leadership.
I still do.
Kim had a quiet reliability about him,
unlike the usual loud gregariousness that people tend to associate with grunts.
He was low key and dependable and for some reason I can still see the way a
smile would creep over his face when stupid shit was going on and he laugh in a
way that made it seem like he was seeing a deeper joke that you didn't get yet.
Doc,
the Dia was new to the company and my memories of him are vague,
but the men who knew him better describe a young corpsman who is enthusiastic
about that his job.
The funny thing with Korman is that sometimes you don't need to know much to
judge their character besides the fact that these young men volunteered for one
specific duty to save the lives of their marines in combat.
A more honorable calling is hard to find.
It's easy for today to be dark,
to get sucked into the trap of loss,
regret,
depression and anger.
It's easy to drown it in liquor under the pretense of having one for the boys.
But this morning as we prepare ourselves to face the 10th of these days,
we think of Scott and his booming laugh.
He wouldn't want us sitting around morning like saps,
wasting our precious days,
burdened with his death,
like tormented widows out of some 19th century romance fiction.
He'd remind us that we all joined up for the same reasons.
Yeah,
we are infantry marines.
We wanted to fight to energetically meet the enemy in battle and crushed him
to serve be beside men with whom we would build a bond stronger than most we'll
ever know.
While the politics are complicated and the outcomes unclear,
one thing is certain,
their sacrifice was not in vain
as it was the sacrifice that warriors make for each other.
April 2nd is a day that defines us now brings us together as brothers.
It is a day of remembrance and reflection
a day that gives us reason to look at our lives and say,
look,
you son of a bitch.
This is why you have to live life to the fullest.
This is why you must fight every day to be a better man.
And then we must just remember that Scott Procopio would call you a pussy for
doing the opposite.
Semper fi,
gents.
We will never forget you.
So that was a post.
Yeah,
that someone forwarded to me that was on reddit
and it was from an anonymous marine.
Obviously this marine was from the three eight marines who we served with in
Ramadi who were
just outstanding warriors.
And I thought that that tribute
not only to the fallen,
but also a form of council
to his fellow marines.
Okay.
I just thought that that was a amazing piece of writing and I wanted to share it
with everyone
April 2nd.
Now,
speaking of Ramadi,
which
you know,
just like this marine,
it's something that I think about all the time and something that I refer back
to in a couple podcasts ago.
We talked about the band of brothers,
the first of the five Oh six who we also served with in Ramadi
and
it is a
but truly hallowed unit and if you've seen the HBO mini series band of brothers,
just a fantastic memorial and representation of these American fighting men and
the leader of that group or one of the,
one of the leaders of easy company and then of the battalion was a guy by the
name of major dick winters and
he wrote after after his,
after he came famous really from the first book by Steven Ambrose called Band of
brothers and then the mini series came out called band of brothers.
He wrote a book which is called beyond band of brothers,
the war memoirs of Major Dick Winters.
Okay.
I got to this book basically because I was going to do band of brothers,
the Stephen Ambrose,
but as everybody knows or if you don't know,
I like to get the source of material from the people that were there,
Steven amorous as a historian and so I identified this book as I was researching
more deeply into band of brothers.
I very quickly found this book,
ordered it,
and yeah,
there's no doubt.
So
want me to kick this off?
As battalion operations officer Hester pointed to where an enemy machine gun was
located in approximately where a four gun battery of one oh fives was situated.
That was all he knew.
Captain Hester turned to me and said,
there's fire along that hedge road there.
Take care of it.
That was the sum of my orders.
No detailed battle plan,
no intelligence,
summery,
nothing but a specific tasks to be accomplished without delay.
Easy Company's mission was to silence the battery.
And we talk about the basic principles of combat.
One of them is simple,
clear,
concise.
There you go.
That's your orders.
There's fire long that hedge row take care of it.
And this is also obviously an unbelievable example of decentralized command.
You go solve this problem.
And his response is,
I got it back to the book conducting a mental estimate of the situation.
I viewed any infantry assault on the battery as a high risk opportunity since
our air forces had failed to destroy the artillery battery in the preliminary
bombardment prior to the seaborne invasion.
Our key would be initiative and immediate appraisal of the situation,
skillful use of the terrain and our ability to destroy one gun at a time.
So you'll notice he's going to,
he's already,
as soon as he knows that there's multiple guns.
What does he decide to do?
One gun at a time,
solve one problem at a time,
a little something we like to call it prioritize and execute.
The first thing I did was have everybody drop all equipment except ammunition
and grenades for that was all we would need if things went from good to bad to
get rid of the things you don't need.
Focus on this one task that we've got right now.
It's another prioritize and execute order right there.
While the noncommissioned officers prepared the men for the assault,
I conducted a hasty reconnaissance of the enemy position,
a leader gains and advantage in combat if he's able to appraise the terrain and
the situation quickly and correctly.
Crawling along the hedge row,
I moved to a position where I could get a better view of the enemy position.
The guns appeared to be set in the trench and the head row in the hedge row
covered by machine gun fire from across an open pasture.
The battery was firing directly down causeway number two in a direction of Utah
beach where the initial waves of the fourth infantry division,
we're already landing.
So you've got these German guns in an elevated position hammering Utah Beach
where the Fourth Infantry Division is trying to land right now.
It's a nightmare.
Anticipating that it would be too costly to conduct a frontal attack across an
open field.
I determined our chances of success would be greatly enhanced if we could hit
the enemy on the flank and silence one gun at a time,
hit the enemy on the flank.
Again,
these are basic principles and I hate calling.
I hate using the word basic because it's fundamentals.
There's nothing basic about it.
It's basic,
but it's,
it's beautiful,
beautiful in its simplicity.
Returning to the company,
I assigned specific missions to each man so everybody knows what their task is
going to be.
First I placed one of easy companies,
two machine guns in a position where they could provide covering fire.
As we move carefully into position covering move,
cover and move.
Next I divided our detachment into two units,
one led by Lieutenant Buck Compton and the other remaining with me Compton move
down one hedge row with Sergeant Garnier and Malarkey to get as close to the
first gun in the battery as possible.
Why led my unit down a parallel hedgerow Compton also sent sergeants,
Lipton and rainy to come to a concealed position to put flanking fire on the
enemy while my detachment crawl Ducote cross the open field to approach the gun
first.
So you've got multiple cover and move situations going on right now and again to
the,
to the military folks that are listening to this,
you could breeze through this description and and miss how important that is.
How important and what a great example of cover moved.
This is got to put down that cover fire.
You got to put down that cover fire and that's why you've got to bring them
heavy weapons out there.
Bring those AWS out boys.
Lots of them.
When my group back to the book,
when my group consisting of Corporal Joe Toy,
Pfc Robert,
Popeye win and private Gerald the rain from regimental headquarters reached the
hedge that led to the enemy position.
We stopped here.
I placed a second machine gun to engage the first gun that was firing point
blank at us.
I gave the gunner instructions not to fire unless he saw definite target so he
would not give away his position.
Then we worked our way up to Compton's hedge row here.
I spotted a German helmet and squeezed off two rounds later.
I found a pool of blood at this position,
but no Jerry and Jerry's term for German.
Next I sent Compton with two men along the hedge to throw hand grenades at the
enemy position while the rest of us supported him with covering fire.
These guys don't do anything without covering fire.
I fired occasionally to fill spots when there was a lull in the covering fire
due to putting in new clips.
Compton took too long getting his detachment into position and we spent more
ammunition than we should have,
but in return,
we receive no enemy fire.
So that covering fire,
even though it took too long,
but,
but they didn't receive any enemy fire because they were laying down that fire.
They were laying down that call covering fire just as Compton was ready to hurl
his grenades.
I started across the field with the rest of the assault team so that what we
jumped into position together as the grenade exploded simultaneously,
we hurdle additional grenades at the next position.
In return,
we received substantial small arms fire and grenades from the enemy.
As we approached the first gun,
Popeye wind was hitting the button and fell down in the trench rather than
complaining that he was hit.
He apologized.
I'm sorry,
Lieutenant.
I goofed.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
my God.
It's beautiful.
When you think of a guy who is so dedicated to his company that he apologizes
for getting hit.
Now.
Here was a soldier,
he hit by enemy fire in Normandy on d day behind German lines and he's more
upset that he led his buddies down.
Then he was concerned with his own injury.
Popeye's action.
Popeye's actions spoke for all of us.
Now I'm fast forwarding a little bit too.
They get these,
they get these guns taken down with the entire battery now destroyed.
We now withdrew because the machine gun fire that we were receiving from the
Manor House and other positions remained intense.
I pulled our own machine guns out first.
Then the rifleman,
I was last to leave and as I was leaving I took a final look down the trench and
there was one wounded Jerry trying to put a machine gun onto,
into operation.
I drilled him through the head.
On our way back.
I came across Warren,
officer j g Andrew Hill,
who had been killed working his way up to help us in all.
We had suffered for dead six wounded and we had inflicted 15 dead in 12 captured
enemy German forces in the vicinity.
The battery had outnumber,
had numbered about 50 about three hours passed since I had received the order to
dispose the battery.
Yeah,
and then so they,
they take care of that.
They conduct some other smaller operations and then it goes to the sort of the
end of d day.
At long last d day was over.
Our success had been to suburb leadership at all levels and the training we had
experienced prior to the invasion,
add luck to the equation and easy company comprised a formidable team on
reflection.
We were highly charged.
We knew what to do and we conducted ourselves as part of a well oiled machine
because we were so intimate with each.
I knew the strengths of each of my troopers.
This is something that he refers back to a lot,
was really understanding his men and what they were like,
what drove them,
what their strengths and weaknesses were so he could put them in the correct
positions.
Evening allowed us a few minutes of quiet reflection with our outposts in place.
I stretched out to catch a few hours of sleep,
even though the rattle of German small arms fire continued throughout the night
before I dozed off.
I did not forget to get on my knees and thank God for helping me live through
this day and to ask his help on d plus one
I would live this war one day at a time and I promised myself that if I
survived,
I would find a small farm somewhere in Pennsylvania countryside and spend the
remainder of my life in quiet and peace.
Now.
Okay,
you're going to you as you,
as you hear about Dick Winners and that's I,
I wanted to cover at least one engagement on actual engagement and that's,
that's one of them.
So you can kind of see the methodology,
the,
the principles that he's putting into action.
But you know,
I want to concentrate not so much on the action now,
but more on the leadership,
the leadership pieces of it,
although they're still be,
I still do talk about some of the,
some of the combat situations that they get into because they were in a war,
but I want to check in going back a little bit from where he came from,
what his mindset,
what developed it and he,
he says this,
I had a wonderful mother,
very conservative.
She came from a Mennonite family but never converted to that faith.
Honesty and discipline were driven into my head from day one.
At some point,
am I just going to have to stop?
Like even accenting these things,
these common themes that are just run through these,
these leaders?
Not surprisingly,
I'm mother was undoubtedly one of the most influential people in my life.
A mother takes a child,
she nurtures him,
she instills disciplined and she teaches respect.
My,
this is my mother was the first one up every morning.
She prepared breakfast for my sister and in me and she was the last one to bed
every evening.
In many respects.
She was the ideal company commander and subconsciously I'm sure I patterned my
own leadership abilities on this remarkable woman.
So it's interesting he all he talked about was that she was the first one to
work and she was the last one to leave work meetings.
She was the first one up in the morning and she was the last one to leave.
And with that statement alone,
he said that she's the ideal company commander.
Now for those of you that aren't in the military,
a company commander is,
is there's several companies in a battalion,
there could be three,
maybe four,
maybe even five,
depending on the task organization,
but it's,
it's a hundred,
maybe 150 guys generally in a,
in a company.
So he's saying that this,
that his mom would be a ideal company commander.
Why?
Because she wakes up early and has a lot of discipline.
Newsflash,
now
speaking of,
yeah,
I won't read any more actions.
Here's another action.
I positioned men on both sides of the road and prepared to move out in order to
secure the intersection.
So here they are on a move.
They've got a secure,
an inter intersection.
Lieutenant Welsh led first platoon at the head of the company column precisely
on schedule.
I hollered Welsh,
move out.
Just as the attack started,
a German machine gun located in a building at the foot of the hill,
started to fire up the road.
The German gun crew was in perfect position at the perfect time to wipe out our
entire attack from the left hand side of the road.
Welsh pushed six men towards the intersection.
They went straight at that intersection and the enemy machine gun.
The enemy fire,
however,
was very effective.
Our men on both sides of the road kept low profiles in the ditches,
had heads down and they frozen place leaving Welsh and his six men assaulting
the intersection alone
to my rear colonel.
Strayer and his staff,
including Captain Hester and Nixon could see what was happening.
They in turn were hollering at me,
get them moving winters,
get them moving.
I struggled out of my harness to rid myself of excess equipment so that I could
run.
Since it was obvious what needed to be done.
So guess what?
People aren't moving.
People aren't taking action and it's obvious to him what needs to be done.
Standing in the middle of the column on the right hand side of the road,
I hollered,
move out,
move out.
This did no good.
Everyone had his head's down.
This was the one and only time in the war that I really blew my top and
physically kicked ass.
I came out of that ditch with only my m one in hand and hollering.
I ran to the head of the column,
kicked ass on the left side of the road,
then ran to the right side of the road,
back and forth,
screaming at my top of my voice.
Get going.
I will never forget the surprise and fear on those faces looking up at me with
me running around on the road like a wild man.
The machine gunner seem to zero in on me.
I was a wide open target.
The bullets snapped by and glanced off the road all around me for shirt.
Short time I had the feeling of being blessed.
That feeling didn't last too long for hours to find out in a few minutes that I
wasn't so blessed.
And the reason I highlighted that section right there,
because in the next,
literally the next page in the book,
you know,
you get this idea,
and again this is this,
the idea that people have of military leaders is that they're these hard ass
guys and these kick ass guys that are running around and yelling like what I
just read
and that I wanted to highlight that because now we fast forward one page in the
book,
in taking the intersection,
easy companies sustain 10 casualties among our wounded were sergeant Lipton,
Ed Tipper and Burst Smith.
Another casualty was private.
Albert bleive who was in the aid station sitting with his back against the wall
when I entered to have my wound cleaned because by the way,
major winners got to hit.
And so he's in there getting his a wound clean.
Now he's looking at private life and he says,
and he says here,
I did not notice any wounds.
So I asked how you're doing life?
I can't see.
He replied.
I remember trying to comfort him by saying,
it's okay.
Be Life,
relax.
We'll have you out of here as soon and they'll send you back to England.
As I started to move away,
blight stood up suddenly saying,
I'm okay.
I can see now.
As soon as blight regained his vision,
he immediately returned to duty.
If you think about that for a minute,
that boy had been paralyzed by fear,
yet he had the guts and dedication to stick to his buddies and easy company.
As soon as he relaxed and pulled himself together,
he returned to the front.
Rather than taking the easy way out with an evacuation,
sometimes all a soldier needed was a calm voice,
reassuring him that everything was fine.
In [inaudible] case,
he rejoined the company and it was wounded in action.
During the upcoming fight after World War II,
he served in the hundred 87th airborne regiment and the Korean War where he was
awarded a Silver Star and the bronze star,
by the time he retired from military service life was a company first sergeant.
So the contrast there is that,
you know,
instead of pulling a general George Patton and slapping the guy around and
saying,
you're not wounded,
get he realized what he needed to do,
which was just with the guy and say,
hey listen,
everything's gonna be all right.
We'll get you on a plane,
we'll get you back to England.
Just just take it easy.
Here's a section that I'm just going to jump too quickly.
When he's talking about the confusion,
getting in the confusion and getting our men into position was as bad as we were
to ever see.
One time I found easy company troops firing into troops of another battalion.
Later we had some tank show up for support and they began firing into our own
line.
So that's blue on blue,
it's fratricide and you know,
we talk about it in our book and it's one of those things that they usually
don't show it.
They usually don't portray it because it's hard to believe that things can get
that confusing,
but they do
and it goes all the way back
and clear example right there.
Now we're going back to blight.
And this is an interesting commentary on training on one of our daylight patrols
led by Sergeant Garnier blight was point man when he spotted a German sniper and
a tree
just as he did in training,
he automatically said Bang,
Bang,
instead of dropping to the side of the road and putting his rifle on the sniper.
So if you can imagine you're back in America or that when they were doing their
pre pre uh,
attack training in England and they weren't using real bullets,
so they're out on a patrol and if they saw something and go bang,
Bang,
well that's literally what the guy did.
The German reacted first and shop life through the collarbone,
the rest of the patrol,
recovered life and then withdrew to easy la easiest lines.
So again,
military people that are listening,
law enforcement,
you train how you fight and you fight how you trade.
So you just got to keep that in mind all the time.
If you're giving yourself some kind of a training scar by doing something like a
lip gun.
We actually did this in seal team lip gun was what we called it.
Embarrassing.
You know they my early days,
that's what we,
we didn't have a choice like what you make sound like your mouth.
Yeah.
Thank [inaudible] and you know,
thankfully now they have Brino unbelievable good systems.
You know the paint ball type systems that go in are real guns,
the laser tag type systems so we don't have to use lip guns
back to the book.
Next sector success breeds confidence and easy company.
Success in Normandy instilled the confidence that they would need to succeed and
live to fight another day.
At the same time I could not help but think that had I trained the men harder,
if I had done a better job,
maybe more of my men would come home.
That's something that a leader is always going to be thinking.
Always going to be thinking that what could we have done better?
What could I have done better?
Now they,
they get back to England,
they're taking a break.
They get pulled off the line and he's back in Al and Alice born.
He's just talking about,
he sort of reflecting back on his initial push into Europe
and you know,
you got guys that are out drinking and doing whatever they're doing and he says,
as for myself,
I relaxed.
The Best I could.
Combat had made me tense,
particularly since my decisions now meant life or death to the members of my
command.
Commanding soldiers in combat requires a personal detachment from the men
themselves.
In a sense,
command is the loneliest job in the world.
Looking at myself in the mirror,
I could see how much I had changed.
I could sense it.
Another thing that affected me was the importance of discipline,
the necessity of instilling discipline in my troops and getting the job done in
combat.
In an attempt to escape the tension that combat had caused,
I developed a heavier than usual exercise regimen and I attended church on a
regular basis.
There were only a few days that I didn't run two to three miles,
do 80 pushups,
60 setups on a foot locker that a couple of splits and some leg and trunk
exercises after the day's work was over.
As a result,
I kept in pretty good shape,
not what I'd call wrestling shape,
but good enough for army work.
Physical activity kept me mentally alert,
built my endurance and kept me supple.
You gotta do it.
You got to have that discipline and you've got to work out.
You got to do it every day.
It's that important.
Yeah.
You see how he mentioned how it kept him mentally sharp?
It absolutely does.
Yeah.
It's it.
That'd be four.
We're,
that's,
that's one of the few things that you can do that affects everything.
Everything in life.
Yeah.
You are correct.
I think people a lot of time in,
in regards to the exercise,
people think,
well,
exercise,
that's for a certain kind of person.
You know,
maybe a fitness person or something like that.
It's for a dumb jock,
right.
If a smart person,
so I'm not going to exercise or wrong answer.
Yeah.
I think nowadays people are more hip to it for sure.
But um,
did you say hip hitmen yeah.
Down Down with the cause.
The new stuff.
Yeah.
But yeah,
it is.
Um,
it's interesting how these leaders back then they knew that Yup.
Even though there's been no,
even though at that
time there'd been no scientific study there,
scientific studies now that prove it,
he didn't know that.
He just knew it.
He felt that he lived it.
You lived it,
you know,
now they're in a position.
Now again,
I'm just fast forward.
And even though I said it wasn't gonna cover too much of the combat I'm covering
the combat it give the combat is what is what puts these people in these
leadership positions.
Lee Combat is the ultimate teacher,
the harshest teacher.
And it teaches you lessons that you do not forget.
So there are around this village of Foi,
which is a village that was held by the Germans and they'd been waiting and
you'd been,
you'd been awhile and hears,
winter's talking about here's winters talking about his troops.
They were now completely exhausted.
They had had no hot food.
Little sleep,
no rest,
constant tension and the pressure of combat.
The worst time was night when temperatures plummeted and fog covered the
battlefield until mid to late morning.
The uncertainty of what lay just yards ahead in the next tree lawn was
sufficient to break ordinary men.
Not surprisingly,
the men became physically exhausted.
Physical exhaustion leads to mental exhaustion,
which in turn causes men to lose discipline.
Loss of self discipline then produces combat fatigue.
Self-Disciplined keeps a soldier doing his job
without it.
He loses his pride and he loses the importance of self respect and the eyes of
his fellow soldiers.
It is pride that keeps a soldier going and keeps him in the fight.
This is what I feared.
I would lose the loss of will to measure up to my men.
After seeing others breakdown,
you wondered who is next and you started taking a hard look at yourself.
I often wondered why I didn't break under the strain of combat.
One factor undoubtedly lay in the fact that my battalion headquarters lay 75
yards behind the Ford foxholes.
No longer was I under enemy observation.
Consequently,
I was able to concentrate on my duties without fear of enemies,
small arms fire.
Another factor was undoubtedly my physical conditioning.
I don't think there was a man in the battalion who is in better physical shape
than I was.
My responsibility to ensure the safety of the soldiers also hardened me to cope
with the daily stress of combat.
One last observation on combat fatigue.
When you see a man break,
he usually slams his helmet down and messes up his hair.
I don't know if it's conscious or unconscious,
but a soldier goes to his head and massages.
His head shakes it and then he's gone.
You can talk to him all you want,
but he cannot hear you when he reaches that point.
The best thing for everybody is just to let him take a walk.
Combat exhaustion occurs instantaneously.
You don't plan to become a combat fatigue casualty.
How do you prevent combat fatigue?
You talked to your troops and make some excuse to pull a soldier off the front
line.
Of course,
pulling a soldier off the front line increases the stress of those who remain,
but as a necessary trade.
Off,
I often asked a soldier whom I saw on the verge of a breakdown,
how about coming back with me to the CP to help out for a couple of days in this
manner.
You invent a reason for pulling a guy from the line without damaging his psyche.
So
bunch of stuff there on combat fatigue and,
and I'm not saying that you're going to see combat fatigue and in the civilian
world,
I mean,
but you do see people get stressed out in business.
And I thought that that comment about people messing up their hair and grabbing
their head,
that's a,
that's a really good indicator of when people are,
are breaking.
And I'll tell you one of the things,
this is something that we talk about the book as well as for us,
the guys that had
the most resistance to combat fatigue with the guys that were most integrally
involved in the planning of the operations because they felt like they had some
control.
And unfortunately for us,
we didn't know this.
So we had guys that weren't involved,
like you know,
maybe they were a new guy or maybe they just,
they just weren't that involved in the planning or whatever.
So all they were getting told was like,
hey,
get your gear on.
You're going out again.
Right.
Come back from that operation.
Hey,
get your gear on and going out again.
Come back to that operation.
Hey,
get your gear on and you're going out.
Again,
those guys that didn't really get involved in the planning,
it was harder for them because they didn't feel like they had any control and
they didn't see the risk mitigation that was happening and they didn't
understand the strategy well enough.
Why?
Because I didn't tell him my fault,
you know,
I should have been more engaged in them.
I should have explained to him the impact that they were having.
I should have explained to him the overall strategic picture.
And I tried to do that and I thought I did it,
but I didn't do it well enough.
And those are the guys that definitely were the most stressed out.
So leaders out there,
it's just another reason.
It's another reason to tell people why they're doing what they're doing and get
them involved in the planning and get them ownership of the planning so that
feel I have some control
over it.
Interesting.
I'll eat,
oh,
they mentioned how they dealt with that when they'd pull them off the line.
Right.
But they wouldn't just be like straight up straight dope.
Hey,
you're messing up.
Get off the line.
Nope.
It's like they pulled them off the line in a way that wouldn't,
would it mess them up,
you know,
hey,
we need you to take care of the supply issue.
You can go back there for me and get this figured out.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll do it.
I'll give them a break.
Give them a rest.
There's some Hackworth talked about too.
I mean,
Hackworth says,
um,
you know about face,
you know,
he talks about,
he just says,
hey,
everyone's got a cup of a certain size cup.
Some people have a bigger cup than others,
but when the cup gets filled up,
that's it.
They're done.
And if you let the cup get filled up and overflow,
then they're done forever.
But if you can catch it beforehand,
they can go back a little bit and drain their cup out,
but that's exactly what you talk about when you say you say manipulation,
right?
Like how you'd,
you'd tell them.
Yeah,
just in a kind of a gingerly kind of way to make them,
make them signed on to the whole situation.
Yeah.
No doubt about it.
This is going back to his discipline.
My routine was to shave every morning and then to inspect the line
in Russ.
In retrospect,
shaving in the bitter cold was pretty ridiculous,
but the practice had originated with one of my first meetings with Colonel Sync
at Tacoma sink.
It required us to shave every morning.
He said,
you shave every morning for the men and if you want to shave every evening for
the women,
but that's up to you,
but I want you to set an example.
He was absolutely right.
I remember one morning when we prepared for our attack on Foy,
I got up in the middle of the night to shave before getting something to eat in
the process.
I cut myself up pretty badly.
I must have looked like hell when colonel sink arrived to check on us before the
attack commenced,
he took one look at me and had a huge smile on his face.
I later,
I realized later that he was laughing at me for shaving on that bitterly cold
morning.
But that was one of the things I did to set an example for the men shave in the
morning and once in a while I would strip to the waist and give myself a French
guash,
a routine that caught everyone's attention.
I did this for one reason and one reason only to get the men's attention and to
let them know that I was going to be around for awhile and this wasn't as bad as
they thought it was going to be.
Make the best of it.
And what I like about that is his total awareness is total awareness of the
impact that he's having on his men.
He knows that they are watching them.
If you're in a leadership position,
you've got to recognize that people are watching you parents.
Yeah,
yeah.
If you're a parent,
you got to realize that that person that you're leading called your child,
they're watching you.
It's critical than
most of the time anyway.
Then what you say,
so you know,
and people will make this excuse kind of the saying that to say,
Hey,
do what I say,
not what I do.
Meanwhile,
you're doing all this stuff.
That's not,
that's not how they're going to,
they're going to be like,
oh,
that's just something you say.
Meanwhile,
this is how you do it.
Apparently mom and dad are doing it this way.
That's the way it's done.
Regardless of what they say.
Yeah,
you got to do the right thing and people are watching you.
When you're in a leadership position that you are being watched,
you are being emulated.
Your emotions are being mimicked.
You don't know that.
You might not sense that,
but your emotions are being mimicked.
You get into a panic mode.
You're going to have a bunch of people panicking.
You stay calm.
Your people are going to stay calm.
You get crazy.
You're people are going to go crazy.
You're people are watching you.
So set the good example and one of the premier he examples he setting as he's
maintaining the discipline.
Now this actually section,
I don't,
it's,
it's very interesting because we had,
I had made a comment on the podcast about,
hey,
what do you do?
Someone asked,
what do you do if you get told to do something and you don't believe in it?
Right.
And you know,
I went through a big gray area and said,
look,
you know,
there's,
there's some gray area there and if it's just something small that you could ask
to do and you just,
if you decide you're going to lay down the law right now and bang your fist on
the table and say,
I'm not going to do that,
well then you're going to get fired and now someone else is going to have to
come in there and do that thing that you've been asked to do.
And I had one person on Twitter that kind of went back and forth with me and you
know,
uh,
he said,
hey,
it does make an impact when you walk away.
And I agreed with him.
I said,
yes,
I know I,
I'm not trying to say it doesn't make an impact when you walk away cause it
certainly does,
but there's cases where it has more of an impact if you stay and you stay in the
game.
So this is an example right here.
A pretty shocking example because we have a guy that's 100% on board and is,
you know,
a straight shooting guy that listens to his chain of command.
And here's what happens.
Colonel Bob Sink was a magnificent commander,
but this time he had had a little too much to drink and is ordered to dispatch
another patrol to capture additional prisoners did not make sense.
We had already captured sufficient prisoners for interrogation.
A second patrol would only result in casualties for no apparent reason.
Further exacerbating the situation was freshly fallen snow along the river that
it quickly turned to ice during the day.
If I followed Colonel Sinks,
order,
the enemy would have heard us coming along way off
what to do.
I responded,
yes sir.
And then promptly ignored the order
so that he's doing what I was basically what I was saying.
Like if he just said,
no sir,
we're not going to do that.
Guess what?
He's going to get fired and now we're going to get someone else put in charge.
And even if he doesn't get fired,
he's hurting his reputation.
So it's a bad situation,
but what he decides to do is go,
got it sir,
we'll take care of it.
And then he promptly ignores the order to now back to the book to give the
impression of compliance.
However,
I assembled the men in a building and told them we are not going to send out
this patrol because I did not think it was feasible.
I also informed them that my neck was in a noose.
If anyone ever said anything about it.
With that the men lay down and caught some much needed sleep and I took the
radio and adjusted mortar and artillery fire on my supposedly objective
and here's his,
here's his thoughts on it.
On reflection,
I did exactly the right thing and I have never had any regrets.
There was insufficient time for preparation.
The field to our front was wide open and I would have lost too many men for no
purpose.
I wonder what I would've done had I been a career officer concerned about my own
future,
would I have compromise my beliefs,
the deliberate disobedience of a lawful order by my commanding officer presented
in an ethical dilemma of the first magnitude.
But
you can see it's a guy who's staying on his principles and his principles were
to accomplish the mission,
take care of his men,
and he's weighing those things.
Those things aren't black and white.
Those things are not black and white because you look at all the times he did do
operations in missions and tasks.
These were his guys got wounded and killed.
But he saw what the purpose was and now we see something where there's no
purpose.
And he says,
you know what,
not going to do it.
But he doesn't tell the boss.
He just does an executed.
So it,
and you know there's stories of seals and Vietnam doing that.
And I heard that from,
from the Vietnam seals would tell me,
hey,
if they got directed to do something that they didn't think was a good mission.
I've talked about this before.
Oh,
we're going to go,
you want us to go three kilometers away and set up an ambush on this river
that's in really tough enemy controlled areas and we don't know what the
intelligence is on who's going to come down that river.
Okay,
cool.
And they'd patrol 200 meters out the gate,
set up a little perimeter,
right close to camp where there's no,
no problems.
Smoke a couple cigarettes,
spend a few hours out there.
Walk back.
Yeah.
Hey,
nothing happened.
No one came down the river.
I would think you'd have to be pretty responsible though,
if you're going to kind of exercise that course of action.
Otherwise you get someone who's just like Noo Noo don't feel like you don't feel
it.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's obviously something that a guy like Dick winters did very rarely and the
seals in Vietnam.
So I think they were blowing missions off all the time.
Right.
But they,
you know,
like I said,
if,
if something comes up where you completely disagree with it,
but you don't disagree with it to the point where you want to make,
you want to make,
um,
make a stand that's gonna make you get fired or now you're not supporting your
guys anymore.
Yeah.
You know?
Okay,
you cool.
You kept him alive that night.
Well,
who's coming in to take your place,
right?
That's the question.
Who's coming in to take your place and you don't know who that is and what's
their best interests going to be.
Because whoever comes in to take your place is going to be a company guy that's
going to be,
you know,
he's going to be a guy that's going to obey every last direct order from the
guy.
And this is,
you know,
it's,
it's strange too.
I mean,
here I am,
I'm a,
I mean,
I was,
uh,
as,
as motivated it to be in the military as I could possibly be.
You know,
so I'm not sitting here calling from mutiny from guys,
right.
But I am telling you to use common sense and you've got to put common sense on
top of everything.
And sometimes common sense outweighs or orders.
That's just the way it is.
It's rare.
And I said this last time as well,
it's rare.
It's not like you're getting these crazy orders from up the chain of command.
People aren't,
people aren't advancing in the military because they're,
because they're idiots.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
And it's not like they're not on your team and it's not like they want you to
get killed.
And you know,
maybe,
you know,
in this case he could have gotten given some push back and said,
hey,
you know what boss,
here's what's going on.
There's fresh snow,
it's good.
They're gonna hear is coming a mile away.
We don't have good cover to the front.
This is not a good operation.
But maybe he heard the tone of the colonel's voice and just said,
hey,
this guy,
it'd be if I say that and then I don't do it,
or if I say that it's gonna make me suspicious so you know what?
I got it sir.
And then don't do it just to judge the judge a judgment of character.
But that's what you've got writing on you and you're in a leadership position.
You know you got those guys lives and that's should be more important to you
than anything.
And it's,
it's a strange dichotomy of leadership because on the one hand you're trained
your whole military career that you've got to take care of your men,
take care of your people.
That's something you get trained on since day one.
Take care of your team.
And the dichotomy of that is you're going to do missions where you could very
well be sending your men to their death.
So there's a massive dichotomy there and how you deal with the dichotomy,
you find the balance and the balance is not a cookie cutter response.
The balance is different for each scenario that you're in and how well you can
weigh those.
Opposing forces
is a,
is a measure of what kind of leader you are.
That's what makes leadership hard.
Now
we're getting to Dave.
They've moved through Europe and now we're about to go from war to
something even more evil,
which is the concentration camps,
the death camps.
So back to the book
as they enter.
This is back to the book.
As they entered the their death camps for the first time,
the horror of what we observed remains with each paratrooper.
To this day,
you could not explain it.
You could not describe it,
and you could not exaggerate it.
It did not take long to realize that the Nazis were intent on eliminating all
the Jews,
Gypsies,
and anyone who disagreed with Hitler's regime,
the memory of starved dazed men who dropped their eyes and heads and we looked
at them through the chain link fence in the same manner that a beaten,
mistreated dog would cringe,
left a mark on all of us forever.
Nor could you underestimate the barbarity of the Nazi regime.
Even during the latter stages of the war.
As I went through the war,
it was natural to ask myself,
why am I here?
Why am I putting up with a freezing cold?
The constant rain and the loss of so many comrades.
Does anybody care?
A soldier faces death on a daily basis and his life is one of misery and
deprivation.
He is cold.
He suffers from hunger frequently bordering on starvation.
The impact of seeing those people behind that fence left me saying if only to
myself
now I know why I am here for the first time.
I understand what this war is all about
and
obviously seeing that evil firsthand
and that's one of the reasons why I think we explore the darkness and the evil
on a fairly regular basis here and that's why I explore it.
That's why my mind is drawn to these things because you got to understand that
evil's out there and it's still here today
and
has got to take the fight to the enemy.
Now
I'm jumping towards the end of the book and again,
it's not really not giving anything away.
I mean we know how World War Two ended,
but this is how
colonel winters,
or sorry,
major winters kind of wraps up their combat
back to the book and so many of the Tacoma veterans returned home yet all would
be forever connected by their shared experiences in combat.
Over the course of the war,
easy company alone lost 48 men killed and over 100 wounded,
incurring 150% casualties.
This percentage was not uncommon among similar units who had fought in the
campaign of northwest Europe
at the peak of its effectiveness in Holland in October of 1944 and in the
Ardennes in January,
1945 it was as good a rifle company as there was in the world.
According to Arthur,
Stephen,
he Ambrose,
how so many men survived the campaigns in Normandy,
Holland,
Bastogne,
and Germany was a true testament to their courage,
their training and their discipline under fire.
Now I,
I want to fast forward a little bit more too.
He's,
he's done.
He's now out of the military and I know we got a lot of people that listen to
the show because a lot of you guys reach out to me and talk about that
transition.
A lot of people ask me about that transition
and here's Dick winters transition.
While I was extremely happy to put the army behind me,
I realized that I was a different man than I was when I joined the army over
four years earlier.
The war had changed me in many ways as it does all who experienced combat
having witnessed so much mass suffering and the unparalleled barbarism that
mankind is capable of inflicting upon itself.
I don't see how any survivor can be ever be cruel to anything.
Again.
In addition,
I was a far better judge of character than I had been in 1941 that feeling
remains with me today,
a full 60 years after the war.
When I meet people for the first time and get know them,
I can't help but judge them and size them up.
Do they have leadership?
Would they be good in combat?
Do they pass the test?
I was also more disciplined than I remembered being before I deployed to Europe.
This discipline helped me adapt to civilian life.
Once I returned to Pennsylvania,
like all veterans,
I had to adjust to society.
The life that you are going to share with others in order to make a living.
I certainly never confused the challenges in the workplace with what I
experienced in combat.
There would be no life and death struggles in the corporate world.
Business hardly equates to war.
Such comparisons demean the word
and when I read that I actually had to put myself into check.
Hmm.
Because I wanted to make sure that I,
I'm clear about something cause something I am obviously we wrote a book that's
about comparing business and war,
but I want to make it clear that what we're comparing and what we say is
similar.
In fact they're the same is that principles,
the principles of leadership are the same.
The struggles and the challenges and the consequences are not the same.
They are not.
So I want to make sure I make that clear.
Now
let's get to some of his reflections on leadership.
Back to the book.
Was I a successful leader?
They tell me I was and modesty prevents me from disagreeing with them.
I am not so naive that I don't realize the wide appeal of Dick Winters today is
based on leadership in combat.
I may not have been the best commander,
but I always strove to be.
My men depended on me to carefully analyze every tactical situation to maximize
the resources that I had at my disposal to think under pressure and delete them
by personal example.
I think it's interesting even here,
you know,
he's looking back and he's a humble guy.
You know,
I may have not been the best combat commander,
but I always tried to be.
This is a humble man.
I am not sure there is such a thing as a natural born leader.
Some leaders are born with special aptitudes or talents,
but any success I might have had was the product of good upbringing,
intense study and preparation and physical conditioning that set me apart from
my peers.
Here's Dick Winters.
I mean one of the kind of combat leaders at the tactical level in the modern era
and he's saying that it was preparation and physical conditioning,
the setting him apart from his peers.
I was all back to the book.
I was also surrounded by a group of men who were disciplined and highly trained
to accomplish any mission.
Add luck to the equation and you can understand that.
The secret to my success was that somehow I always manage to survive.
Another day.
In recent years I've been asked to address an increasing number of civic groups,
corporate seminars and governmental agencies on the subject of leadership.
Most are looking for cookie cutter solutions as to what constitutes a successful
leader.
What is the recipe for success and this is,
this is classic and and actually win win the book.
When when Lafe and I,
the book came out and when our book came out we did a bunch of interviews that
got turned into either short articles or video clips in and they would,
they title these things,
you know,
like three things every leader must do and that's what they always do.
Everyone's looking exactly for what he says.
Most are looking for cookie cutter solutions to what constitutes a successful
leader.
What is the recipe for success?
In truth,
there are no simple solutions just as there is no average day in combat.
Each situation is different and each requires a leader to be flexible in
adapting his or her particular leadership style to the specific circumstances
required to accomplish any mission.
It's a matter of adjusting to the individual and you do this every day.
You don't have just one way of treating people.
You adjust yourself to whom you are talking.
If I were to give advice to a young leader going to war,
based on my observation of what I had constituted,
the success of the outstanding leaders who comprise the mill,
the American parachute,
infantry regiment,
regimens of World War II,
I would offer a series of principles that I am certain will result in great
success regardless of the field endeavor,
field of endeavor in which the individual was participating.
So here he's saying the same thing that I say,
which is leadership is the same.
Whether it's in the battlefield or whatever endeavor you're going into.
Leadership principles stay the same.
First and foremost,
a leader should strive to be an individual of flawless character,
technical competence and moral courage.
If you have character,
that means you are the guy that means the guy you are dealing with can trust
you.
The men trust you,
have faith in you and they obey you.
No questions asked.
That's character in a nutshell.
Character also allows you to make decisions quickly and correctly.
Some may question my decision to disobey a direct order from my commanding
officer.
This is the story we already talked about and to fake another patrol as a
violation of that very principle.
I'm advocating
in my heart.
However,
I could not send my men to risk their lives for no apparent reason when clearly
nothing would have been gained that we had not already achieved such a course
takes a degree of moral core courage,
which I have found is far rarer than physical courage.
Was I correct?
In my estimation?
I thought so and I have never regretted my decision.
The same holds true for developing leaders of competency.
Those entrusted to lead must study their profession to become totally proficient
in tactics and technology.
Prior to the invasion,
I read every tactical manual I could lay my hands on to improve my tactical
knowledge and professional competence.
While other soldiers were out carousing and the pubs,
while they were enjoying the social life of the neighboring towns,
I was reading and educating myself,
getting ready to lead men into combat,
getting smarter,
opening up the books.
That's what he was doing and that's part of leadership.
That's part of his is characteristics of leadership is to become knowledgeable,
to read and study.
He goes on,
don't waste time attempting to define leadership.
No need to go to a dictionary.
The infantry school at Fort Benning,
Georgia,
Georgia has defined leadership and just two words via its motto,
follow me
and he's gonna do it again right here.
Physical fitness is another prerequisite for success.
I freely admit that I was blessed with a sound physical constitution,
but whenever possible,
I took the opportunity to improve my physical stamina because I was in such good
physical shape.
I easily survive to Koa.
That's their,
their initial training that they went through for airborne while men washed out
on a daily basis.
The contingent from easy company that completed the training and earned their
wings at Fort Benning were tough as nails because I was in such good shape.
My fatigue level never reached the point of physical exhaustion that contributes
to mental exhaustion and ultimately to combat fatigue.
We all experienced sleep deprivation at times.
That is the nature of stress,
but if physically exhausted leader routinely makes poor decisions in times of
crisis
and here he talks about
another piece.
I have always felt that my principle contribution to the success of both easy
company and second battalion was based on my knowledge of what to expect from
each man.
No your people
having selected the right men for the right job.
I then delegated the authority to my subordinates and allowed them to use their
initiative to execute the mission.
Do you centralize command,
decentralized command?
There is no need to tell someone how you how to do his job if you have properly
trained your team.
Good preparation is always vital to the success of any operation.
But leaders must remain flexible once the action commences.
Steve Ambross likes to quote General Eisenhower who claimed before the battle is
joined plans or everything.
Once the battle is joined,
however,
plans go out the window.
Next,
I would encourage leaders to take a moment of self reflection before rushing
into important decisions.
This is a little bit of detachment.
Many leaders don't take the time to consider carefully their decisions or the
implications of their actions in battle.
I periodically detached myself mentally from the noises and the chaos of battle.
Yeah,
I found it useful to separate myself momentarily and to carefully think through
what actions I needed to take to accomplish the mission.
Again,
I read this book for the first time last week.
He's the detachment straight out.
He's saying the exact same in battle.
I periodically detached myself mentally from the noises and chaos of battle.
Hang tough.
Never ever give up regardless of the adversity.
If you are a leader of fellow who other fellows look to,
you have got to keep going.
I would also urge leaders to remain humble.
If you don't worry about who gets the credit,
you get a lot more done.
Again,
this is when people ask me,
what's the most important quality of a leader?
I tell them it's humility.
Leaders should assume the blame when the operation fails,
when it succeeds.
Credit the men and women in your team,
they do the lion share of the work and now he's going to talk about humility a
little bit more.
Since the release of the HBO miniseries,
many of us have been flooded with hundreds,
sometimes thousands of letters from adoring fans across the nation.
The attention is certainly flattering and greatly appreciated,
but it remains better to remember Eisenhower's address at Guild Hall Hall on
June 12th,
1945 to an ecstatic British public,
which showered the supreme commander with a tumultuous parade through the
streets of London.
I reminded them,
humility must always be the portion of any man who receives a claim earned in
the blood of his followers and the sacrifices of his friends.
I think anybody that's ever been in a leadership position
and has been called some kind of hero.
Yeah,
we'll think back to that statement.
Humility must always be the portion of any man who receives a claim earned in
the blood of his followers and the sacrifices of his friends.
And I think when you
use that word hero,
it's something that obviously gets thrown around a lot.
Okay?
And here's what
major winners had to say about that.
Perhaps the best characterization of what a true hero consists
is found in a letter sergeant Mike Rainey sent me in January,
1982 shortly before he went back to the hospital for a series of tests.
Historian Steven Ambrose use the passage to conclude band of brothers because
rainy and capsulated the cohesion that became the hallmark of easy company.
In thinking back on the days of easy company,
I'm treasuring my remark to a grandson who asked,
grandpa,
where you a hero in the war?
No,
I answered.
But I served in a company of heroes.
Okay?
And I can tell you that I also served with many,
many heroes,
the guys and in tasking to bruiser,
the guys from two to eight infantry,
the guys from one one AED in the ready,
first,
the soldiers and the marines.
All those brave
men
and some brave women as well.
Okay.
And to those
men and women,
those soldiers and Marines and I was lucky enough to serve with.
I think that this statement right here
from Dick Winters,
okay.
Is something that I think is very fitting.
As I look back on the men of easy company and the closeness we have enjoyed over
the years.
I reminded of the dialogue attributed to a senior German officer bidding
farewell to his men in the HBO miniseries.
Miniseries
paraphrasing his words.
I would say to easy company and the officers and men of the five Oh six
parachute infantry regiment.
Okay.
It has been a long war.
It's been a hard war.
You have fought bravely proudly for your country.
You are a special group of men connected by a bond that only exists in combat.
You've shared the incommunicable experience of war and have been tested under
extreme adversity.
You've shared foxholes and have held each other in dire moments.
You've seen death and if suffered together,
you've lived in an environment totally incomprehensible to those who do not know
war.
I am proud and deeply honored to have served with every one of you.
You all deserve long and happy lives in peace.
I bet each of you God speed and asked the Almighty to shower his blessings on
you and your families now and for generations to come.
And that
okay.
Wraps the book and
yeah,
I was thinking after the last podcast that this was going to be a
lighter one.
And I picked this book specifically because I see Major Dick winters has as an
incredible person,
incredible leader and role model for everyone.
But because we are talking about war,
okay,
there is still tragedy and loss and darkness there
and that's okay.
And do you vets out there like the anonymous marine
that wrote that tribute to his brothers from April 2nd
yeah.
And we know there's hundreds of thousands of veterans that are feeling that
every day.
And if you're having one of those dark days,
it's okay.
It's,
It's okay to feel that darkness
and it's okay to remember it and miss it then hate it and love it.
And it's okay to wish it never happened.
And at the same time to wish it never stopped.
And it's okay to want to take it all back
and at the same time
to want to do it all again.
And,
and if you've got in your mind that,
that,
that you think that people don't understand,
that's okay.
They don't,
but you do.
Do you know,
darkness,
you know,
evil.
But more important than that,
you know,
good.
You know,
light.
And do you know,
laughter and love better than anyone.
So
embrace,
embrace that darkness.
Own it.
Don't look away from it.
Don't bury it in booze or in pills.
Listen,
listen to what Corporal Scott Procopio would have been saying to you.
Live your life.
Embrace your life
with,
with physical activity and with nature and with Jujitsu and with Sohn and with
laughter and guitar and good memories and creativity and discipline.
Discipline yourself
so you can free yourself
and move forward
into the future
where there's no more darkness and no more war
but piece.
Good Evening Echo,
good evening.
Little message to the,
to the,
to the vets out there.
I hear from a lot of veterans and I wanted to know,
I just wanted to let those guys know,
you know,
kind of where I'm coming from,
get a lot of real positive stuff from guys and some guys going through hard
times and I know it.
And you know,
I'm hoping to be able to,
uh,
kind of spread my thoughts are where I'm at and how well what I think of these
things.
Okay.
Cause you know,
if you get guys like
major winners that,
you know,
did everything that he did and war and he came back and you know,
he was able to figure it out and a lot of those veterans were,
and they,
you know,
he said it wasn't an easy adaptation that they made,
but they made it,
they made it.
So I think you got to embrace those things
and
be stronger than them.
And I know,
and I say it all the time,
you gotta you gotta know that darkness.
If you really want to appreciate the light.
And I think the guys that have been to war,
they can do that.
Um,
and,
and life can seem so much better
because you know how bad it can be.
So
speaking of feedback from people,
rough transition right now,
but that's what we do here.
What rough,
rough,
rough transitions.
And you know what,
you know what's interesting about the rough transitions and that that's out
there,
that's listening to me right now or anybody that's not a vet that anyone that's
been through hard times and loss,
it's a big rough transition and you go in and out emotionally and you know,
you'll be feeling like crap one minute and then the next minute you'll feel okay
and you'll be laughing.
And that's,
that's all.
Like I said,
that's okay.
I think a lot of people are scared that they might be
acting the wrong way,
but it's all right.
Yeah,
it's okay.
Yeah.
And just like how you're saying where it may seem like people don't understand
and that's okay cause they don't,
that's so true because,
and this is the way I'll think of it because my best friends are actually,
they're still in the navy seals.
Um,
so I of these are guys that you grew up with,
grew up with,
and spend your best friends ever hit my wedding.
Yeah.
Um,
so I,
a lot of them do.
You don't what I talked to him and stuff.
I just,
in my own head,
I kind of imagine what it's like coming back.
Right?
So if you kind of consider it kind of in a nutshell where you consider,
hey,
what's your biggest problems?
When,
when you're overseas,
when you're in the war,
what are these big problems you got to worry about?
Okay,
then let's factor that in.
Okay.
Then we come home and then,
okay,
let's say in the world your biggest problem is getting shot and dying.
Your men getting shot and die.
Right?
Are you getting
both of your legs blown off or you know,
or whatever,
whatever the,
the,
your biggest problem is as far as weren't worrying about again,
then you come home and on and all your girlfriend or your wife is like,
Hey,
I thought I told you to do those dishes.
And she's flipping out on you.
Yeah.
And so in the back of your mind,
you're kind of like,
okay,
wait,
the comparison that it was two days ago,
I was in the desert,
worried about my legs being blown off and now I'm here.
We're apparently the biggest problem according to my girlfriend and life.
Yeah.
The biggest problem on earth apparently.
Cause she's yelling at me,
she's really mad,
she's mad,
she won't really talk to me and are the dishes.
Yeah.
And it's just not computing,
you know?
And then you go next door and their biggest problem is kind on the same level.
So yeah,
they don't understand.
And you,
in a way,
you're living in this crazy world where I can see how that could kind of get to
you and be like,
man,
am I wrong?
You know?
Yeah.
So one of the things that I,
and you hear me talk about this before is perspective and wanting to see,
I was talking about it from a leadership perspective.
Like I want to think about what my superior is thinking.
Why is he telling me do this?
Let me get his perspective and then what am I,
what are my subordinates thinking,
what is their perspective?
And it's a very useful tool to use in what you're talking about right now.
And I remember I had a situation like that where I was at work and I forget what
was going on,
but something was going on.
Like I think we were,
we were preparing to deploy guys earlier.
There's something major was going on.
There were some major issues.
I think it was Afghanistan and we were getting ready to deploy guys early.
It was a real big spin up and all this stuff.
And literally I come home and,
and I mean I'm,
I'm at work and we're trying to figure out how to put this plan together and
guys are going to point,
it's rich,
get a horrible and you know,
whatever bunch of stress.
I come home and I go,
hey babe,
you know how you're doing.
I sit on my wife and she's
sitting there and all of a sudden she like picks up the phone and someone calls
her or she,
someone calls her,
she picks up the phone and she hangs up.
She's like,
I can't believe this.
And I'm just like,
oh,
I thought something,
you know,
I thought someone died or whatever.
And I said,
I said,
well,
what's wrong,
what's wrong?
And she said,
um,
it was something that along with like the wiggles is the same night as Barney
and I booked both tickets.
So it was some things she was taking the kids to that like the literally did not
matter in Amy way,
shape or form to me at all.
But to her,
you know,
she had spent $22 on these tickets for three kids at the time at $66 and now she
had booked double booked the children for multiple shows.
It was harsh,
dark.
But what I had to do,
his will,
I,
you know,
had to go and perspective in her own world,
man,
that was $66 right?
Yeah.
And it was the kids and it was,
they both wanted to see all the shows or whatever the thing was.
So in her perspective,
in her part of the world,
that's a really big deal.
And so that's,
I think something you're going to do as a,
as a,
as a human.
Always look at what other people's perspectives are.
And you know what if people are pissed off,
if your wife's freaking out cause he didn't do the dishes,
I got some really easy solution to that.
Do this,
just do the dishes.
Yeah.
Good viewer.
It's put on some music and scrubs and pots and pans.
Let's do this and you know what,
I'll scrubs and pots and pans be happy to let's make this happen.
Yeah,
that's good man.
And you know that if you have the ability and kind of the wherewithal to do that
to really,
it's detaching you detach and looking at their situation,
not looking at it from your own personal situation.
If you can manage to do that.
And I think it helps when someone reminds you like,
just like how you say it right now,
and maybe someone will be like,
Hey,
you know what I mean?
Let me,
let me go ahead and remember that next time.
You know all this stuff and I say this to leaders all the time.
When I go out and work with companies,
it,
it's so much of it is just about awareness.
When you become aware of the problem,
you become aware of the mistake or you become aware of the solution and it's
there in front of you,
then it becomes very easy.
The problem is you people aren't aware of how easy it can be to solve some of
these things if you just make this small adjustment to your mentality.
Yeah.
All you're aware of is the fact that you're freaking steaming red lining for the
fifth time.
Your wife told you to do something when,
like I said,
you're worrying about your guys getting killed.
Yesterday's it go.
Yeah.
As one of my buddies used to say when we were coming home from our first
deployment,
he says,
can you believe this?
Tomorrow we're going to get on an aluminum tube and we're going to wake up back
in San Diego.
I was like,
okay man,
take it easy.
Take it easy bro.
Uh,
all right.
Anything else here?
Yes,
we are in fact sponsored by on [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko.
Get some good stuff.
Yeah.
Get some very good stuff.
Um,
I prefer off brain and shroom tech.
What was it?
What does that,
that Bar oh yeah.
Yeah.
The uh,
the warrior bars.
Check out the,
this is the anti iDonate.
That's what I like about it.
So the warrior bar,
it's like a,
it's like,
it's like beef jerky with some spice in it,
in some cranberries and it's tasty.
Yeah.
It's like the tender,
you don't have beef Jerky,
beef Jerky,
but there's that tender be one.
The hand is,
it's,
it tastes really good and like moist.
It's good.
It's not dried.
Right.
So yeah,
get done with those.
Don't eat your donuts,
get your warrior Barson and they're,
they're tasty and a beneficial short and long term benefits.
I like important to you thinking.
Yes.
Dang.
Warrior bar.
Yeah.
That it's kind of a genius solution because you know how people will be like,
Hey,
I'll take my protein shake or worry bar.
It's like made with actual like food styluses it's legit.
So yeah,
you're going to get all of that and you can just get after him all day long
cause cause there you don't,
you just,
you're hungry.
But you think,
Oh God,
what am I going to have right now?
You know,
a doughnut is what you're thinking.
Sure.
Potentially.
Yeah.
On it.com/jocko get it 10 for 10% off.
Boom.
And then of course if you,
while you're online,
if you want to check out the chocolate store,
you can buy shirts if you like them.
And bumper stickers.
Yeah.
We made some bumper stickers while Jocko was,
uh,
not looking,
you'll get one of those be under desk or your bumper,
whatever.
Um,
and if some people indicated that they wanted to donate,
you can donate on [inaudible] dot com as well,
the paypal thing,
the PBL thing,
or on Jocko podcast.com as well.
And Click through Amazon.
We've got some people posting what they're,
what they're buying through Amazon,
which is awesome.
Ah,
yes.
So yeah,
if you're shopping on Amazon and you want to support the podcast,
just click on our link on Amazon and then do your shopping like you normally
would.
Here's the thing,
I don't know if I told you is what I added,
cause
my friends on Twitter is troopers.
They,
um,
a lot of people were indicating that they liked the books that you cover.
They're like,
Hey,
let me,
you know,
get those books.
You know what you should do?
You should link,
you should have the list,
the library of books that you've covered in Lincoln.
So I guess what I did,
Echo Scott neck makes things happen.
That's what I like.
And now no one's on Jocko podcast.com on the top.
I added it on the menu where it says books.
It just his books or I dunno,
it says books.
Okay.
And you click on there to have all the podcasts episodes,
you know the book,
what podcast episode it was on.
You Click on it,
boom.
You can get it.
That's awesome.
All right,
let's get to some questions.
Okay.
Question number one
is taking extreme ownership the same as apologizing for failures or for others'
mistakes.
I'm having difficulty separating these two concepts.
When I tried to take ownership over failures,
does taking ownership of failure generally include in,
I'm sorry,
x occurred,
et Cetera,
et Cetera?
Well,
it isn't just apologizing,
right?
It isn't just saying,
oh,
I apologize,
this happened.
It's part of it.
Part of ownership is apologizing.
If you make a mistake,
you got to own it.
And generally you got to say,
hey look,
I'm sorry this happened.
You got to own that.
There's been a problem or a mistake or an issue.
And that does include other people's mistakes,
but you have to literally take ownership of them.
You can't say,
Hey,
I'm sorry these other people made mistakes.
That's not what I'm talking about.
And it's,
look,
the mistakes that were made were actually my fault.
And,
and another important thing here is you can't just say,
hey guys,
it's all my fault.
You actually need to mean it and you need to believe it yourself.
You need to believe that you failed in the situation to do the right thing or
make something happen or make the right decision or make the right call or do
the right preparation or whatever it is that you were supposed to do.
You need to do that.
You need to believe that.
You can't just say it and then you say,
these mistakes were my fault.
Here's why it was my fault.
And Yeah,
I'm sorry that these things happen.
I apologize with this happening.
And some people see,
sorry as a sign of weakness and,
and honestly there's some,
you know,
some legal situations you might be in or some negotiations that you might be in
where that might be true.
But most of the time,
especially in a working environment like inside of a team Saris.
Okay.
And,
and in fact,
an apology is often the first step in moving forward,
right?
And,
and it's generally going to be a little bit of a blow to your ego
now.
And that's especially true because you're Mr extreme ownership now or Mrs.
Extreme ownership.
Guess what?
That doesn't mean everyone else's.
Not yet.
They'll get there.
But they're not there yet.
So you apologize to someone that's gonna be a big blow to your ego,
especially when someone says you're damn right.
That was your fault.
That's,
that's gonna hurt your ear.
You're going to want to lash back out,
but you can't got to put your ego in check and you got to go,
Hey,
I understand that it is my fault.
You know why I'm saying it's my fault?
Because I truly believe it was my fault because it is because it is your fault.
So you gotta be careful when someone gloats.
Don't let that get your head.
Um,
what,
that's what you have to do.
And it's not just not just for you that you're doing this.
It's because the team,
because the team has to figure out what the problem is.
Someone's got to take ownership for the problem.
That's you.
And then that's how you get the problem solved.
And I'll tell you something else,
and you might have predicted this,
but my,
sorry.
And my apology comes with something else.
99% of the time.
Well,
and that's a good,
right?
So look,
Hey,
I'm sorry that this happened.
This is my fault,
but I'm glad it happened now.
Oh yeah.
Hey,
you know what?
I'm glad we made this mistake.
We made this mistake.
Right now it's gonna set us back a little bit.
Good,
because we're now,
we're not gonna make it with a client.
Oh,
this happened.
This part of the project fell apart.
Good.
Now he can fix it and we know about it.
Oh,
this went sideways.
I missed it.
Good.
I won't let it happen again.
So
throw yourself a little good on the end of your,
sorry.
All right.
Yeah.
A lot of times those problems or mistakes or whatever the,
they add to that experience,
like the experience of being there.
You know,
we're,
let's say you go through a path and you make a wrong turn.
Now you have that experience that that's a wrong turn.
That's what that looks like,
that that's what that feels like.
And guess what?
We're going to avoid that in the future rather than a bunch of situation where
were,
for example,
one in the future where it's more detrimental now you don't run into that.
Yeah,
you learned,
you'll learn exactly the video that said be good.
You learn.
All right,
next question.
Is there a way to be a straight shooter?
Oh,
sorry.
Is there a way to be straight shooter Jocko and not be a jerk or piss people
off?
You know this is,
this is a touchy one
because everybody want,
everybody has so much respect for the straight shooter,
right?
Hey,
that guy's a straight shooter and you want to be a straight shooter.
You don't want to be someone that you don't want to be the opposite.
What's the opposite of a straight shooter?
That's like a liar,
right?
Deceiver,
deceiver,
right?
Yeah,
so of course we want to be the straight shooter.
Let me tell you,
it is very difficult to be a straight shooter with everybody.
Even when you have a tremendous relationship with somebody,
a tremendous relationship with somebody,
can you really be a straight shooter with them?
True straight shooter.
I've been a true straight shooter with probably three or four people in my life,
in my life.
I've been a straight shooter with maybe three or four people.
That's off the top of my head.
But I'm just saying it's not a big number.
It's gotta be something that you are so in sync with,
man.
I'm thinking about that.
I don't think that's even possible for me and my situation,
even though,
cause
it's hard to be a straight shooter with people.
Can you reconcile being a straight straight shooter?
Now consider what that means,
but to be a straight shooter with somebody at all times,
yes.
You can't really do though.
So what do we do instead?
You got to use the indirect approach.
The indirect approach,
and I'm,
I'm talking about this all the time and this is a nuance that people,
people will,
people come out on podcast 12 and they say,
hey,
I heard you say this or not.
I'm going to go remember that question we got asked.
You know,
uh,
do you ever get told you're too direct and too intense?
And it's like,
no,
I don't get told that because I don't believe in being trying to be a straight
shooter with everybody.
What I believe in is trying to get my message across to people so that it gets
absorbed by them and the minute you straight shoot somebody,
they're defenses go up and he becomes problematic.
So some indirect approaches are when you have these discussions with people,
when you use conversation to get your point across,
you know,
hey,
I was looking at this and I was wondering what I could do better.
Can you,
can you help me?
Or you know,
what can we do better?
You know,
you throw in the,
the,
the we on it or you know what?
Then you say something like,
Hey,
you know,
you've got so much going on right now.
Do you want me to take anything off your plate?
You want me to take that thing off your plate?
That,
that's kind of like a small little detail.
Do you want me to handle that?
Or you know,
hey,
it seems like you're having to micromanage this guy over here.
You want me to do you want to come over to go straighten that out and run that
or it seems like this guy has taken up too much of your time.
You want me to take that over or take that person over or
you know what's a good one is,
hey,
can you help me with my team members?
I just want to sit down with you and just like,
have you talked to me about what you see in my team members?
And then when you're,
you're,
you're discussing your team members and other people,
even your peers and what they do good and bad.
But what you're really doing is you're just tossing some things their way,
some little things their way so that they understand and they,
and it's kind of like teaching Jujitsu,
right?
When you teach,
when you teach them,
oh,
teaching anything.
When you teach a move,
you learn it better,
right?
If you make somebody teach a move,
they're going to learn it better.
So when you make someone sit down with you and go through the issues that people
are having,
it actually makes them self reflect.
But they don't know it,
but they reap the results.
They reap the results of it.
So that's a,
that's a crafty one that I've used a bunch.
Um,
let's see.
Here's a good one.
I think I'm letting you down.
I don't think I'm doing a good enough job.
You know,
it's like,
I think I'm just be careful though,
without seems like if you,
if you hit the wrong tone bel air,
because you gotta be careful of all of these.
You've got to be tactful.
Yeah.
Uh,
you can ask some more direct questions,
but when you ask the more direct questions,
you got to be sort of,
you've got to be true.
You gotta be,
you gotta come across as being very truthful in your,
in your inquisition.
So for instance,
Hey,
what was the strategy that you were thinking about over here?
Like before this whole thing of fell apart and whatsapp are,
but you know,
hey,
what are you thinking?
Or,
or,
Hey,
what was,
what were you thinking about when you put this together?
Cause I,
I don't quite,
I don't quite get it.
You gotta be careful.
That's another one that had to be sensitive to that tone can come off bad.
What were you thinking?
Right,
right,
right.
Hey,
hey,
you gotta,
you gotta be soft with you.
So it's much better to be indirect and most of these cases,
and hopefully you can build relationships with people where you can be more
direct or you can get that conversation to be where it needs to be to where you
can get the key critical information across.
But it's very,
very challenging.
And again,
it's not that challenging.
It's not impossible.
I did it with everybody all the time.
I always had got my point across to people always,
you know,
and I'll tell you this is something when I would straight shoot somebody,
I would,
and this is if I really needed to straight shoot somebody,
I would write them a very lengthy email
to say,
hey,
here's what's going on.
Here's what I'm saying.
And I would really craft it with a lot of patients and,
and then I would either do,
once I wrote the email,
I would either use that and wouldn't send it,
but I'd use it as a guide to myself.
Like,
okay,
this is the conversation I'm going to have or I'd send it to him for real.
Like a DL note.
Yeah,
like a DL note.
You know,
I actually read one of those.
I read one of those on,
on,
on um,
or two or the number five,
I think it was number five.
That is one of those things that I did.
I said,
okay,
you know what?
I've got to help this guy out.
Got To be direct with them.
He's making some mistakes.
I want them to do better.
Here's a little deal note for you and get you squared away.
The thing is,
uh,
these,
this is definitely hard,
but it's not impossible.
You got to just have the open mind.
You got to use your tack.
Do,
you got to use your judgment and you got to build relationships and have
conversations with people and,
and know what your intention is.
In the conversation and just keep slowly moving in that direction.
You know,
what a tip,
and I'm going to say this tip because I like when people do it to me when
they're like correcting me or or whatever is sprinkle in little comments about
the stuff that,
that they did.
Right?
Yeah.
That's,
that's a common practice.
But when you do that though,
you add in this yet and,
and that's what I like about you.
You do this,
you know,
so it's the,
so if you add in,
that's what I like about two,
it kind of individualizes that person.
Like I'm the guy who does that,
you know,
that good part.
So it gives them that confidence.
So it's kind of like,
yeah,
tell me more kind of,
kind of attitude.
And then at the end though,
in like something along the lines of like,
yeah,
good,
thanks.
You know,
thanks for the time or whatever and then be like,
I got your back.
Yeah.
Kind of leaf.
There's all kinds of,
we could go over techniques on all night long.
Those are both good ones.
Um,
you know,
another one is like,
hey,
listen,
I think you can be a top performer here.
I think you're going to,
this is,
if you're talking to someone that's,
you know,
like a subordinate.
I think you could be a top performer here.
There's,
here's what you're kicking ass at this,
this,
this and this.
Here's this,
these two things right here.
If we can get these fixed,
you're going platinum.
When we get these big things,
when we get positive,
look at you.
I'm imagining in the sense of you telling me this in like Jujitsu or something.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's DVDs to say,
like when I'd be like,
Hey,
and I'd ask him to say I'm in this position and he'd be like,
be like,
yeah.
Then later on,
you know,
I text him,
it be,
hey,
thanks for going over this with me.
He's like,
yeah bro,
you don't keep it up and you can be like a world champion.
He just say that and I don't know who else.
He probably says that to everybody.
I Dunno.
He's never said that to me.
That's because we hate each other.
But for that moment I'm like,
hell yeah.
You know,
like I hope he corrects me more.
I hope he tells me how to do this.
Cause he obviously believed just like,
are you saying,
you know,
you can be a top performer here.
I'd be like,
yeah,
tell me what else.
What can I do?
What can I do on this?
And actually,
yeah,
the point that you're making is very good point,
which is um,
we know picture go into perspective of the other person and what is it going to
sound like to them.
And that's,
that's a smart thing to do.
So you're,
you're hearing what you would hear if you were them.
Yeah.
Indirect people be indirect.
It's harder,
it's challenging,
it takes more time,
it takes more patients and it is way more effective fact.
Yup.
Talked
about how before,
like some people they'll be like,
hey,
I'm just a,
I'm just,
I tell it how it is,
you know,
I tell her how it is and if you don't like it kind of thing and I go ahead and
do that.
But see how that works out for you.
You know?
See how many people follow you.
See,
many people want to listen to you.
You want to,
people want to be around you even,
you know,
I liked the indirect approach to next question.
Jacko what is the number one philosophical lesson that you've learned from
Jujitsu?
Yeah,
so Jujitsu emphasizes so much of what I believe that it's tough to narrow down,
but I will,
but I will throw some things out there that kind of are part of Jujitsu and are
part of what I believe.
Um,
first of all,
what we just talked about being indirect and indirect attacks flanking,
that's what you have to do.
And you did too.
You have to set things up.
You have to detach.
You have to detach from the chaos and from the emotional.
You cannot get emotional on the mat,
attack the flanks and got to hit people where they aren't expecting it.
You got to have a plan,
but you gotta be ready to adapt.
You've got to constantly improve your position.
You got to have fun while you're doing it.
You got to practice being in bad situations.
You got to make your training as realistic as possible,
right?
These are all things I talk about these in all aspects of combat and in business
and in life,
you gotta be physically fit so your mind stays sharp.
That's,
that's true.
True in Jujitsu.
It's true in combat.
It's true in life.
You gotta know when to tap,
right?
You gotta know when to tap.
You've got a known to give up on a single battle so that you don't lose the
whole war.
Get a train for worst case scenarios.
You've got to start with that person on your back.
Got To start with a person with you in an arm lock
and training for combat.
You got to train for those wars.
Crease snooze.
Well,
you're outnumbered.
You got a bunkered position and they're shooting paint ball at you and you got
down men.
That's what you gotta do.
You gotta train for the worst case scenarios.
And same thing with business.
I worked with like sales groups sometimes and they'll do role playing and I'll
say,
you know,
be the worst customer you can possibly be is that way when this person meets a
normal human,
they know how to knock it out of the park.
Here's another one from Jujitsu.
Basically don't judge a book by its cover,
right?
Cause you don't know if the person that you're about to slap his Jeff Glover or
is dean lister or Jill tutor or Joel tutor,
you don't know what's going to happen.
So don't judge a book by its cover.
Yeah,
I mean,
Dean,
you'd be less apt to slap then you would Jeff Glover.
I guess that's a good point.
I mean,
you can kind of judge by the cover.
The cover is pretty evident,
but Jeffe or Joel.
Yeah.
You know,
those guys weigh 150 pounds and they're,
you know,
a surfer guy and uh,
and uh,
whatever Jeff is,
I don't know what genre of human you put Jeff into,
but you wouldn't think that he would throw a Darce choke on your face.
Uh,
so that's that prioritize and execute in the Jujitsu.
I mean,
we just talked about it 14 times tonight for combat.
Talk about in business all the time.
You got to make sure that the initiatives that you're running,
you don't have 38 initiatives and Jujitsu,
guess what?
You hear this all the time.
You get your,
you're about to get choked.
You got to protect your neck.
Number one,
you've got to protect your neck.
Then you can worry about your leg and then you can worry about your arm and the
hooks and everything else.
But you got to protect the neck.
You've got to prioritize,
prioritize,
got to keep things simple.
You got to create,
you've got to have an open mind.
You gotta be creative and look for different ways to win and different things to
do.
You gotta make sure you don't get trapped into new ruts mentally trapped in a
row.
This happens to me,
everybody.
I think,
yeah,
it happens to me,
but I only know what I can tell you about me and that is I get trapped and ruts.
Would you Jitsu [inaudible] where I get,
I get stuck in something and I'll just go with one move for a long period of
time.
You gotta be careful that I need to be better about that.
Discipline equals freedom.
So with Jujitsu,
the more disciplined you are in training,
the more freedom you have on the mat.
So the more you train,
the more you work,
the more you drill,
the more you can move,
the more you can escape,
the more you can create,
the more you can finish.
Yup.
And not to mention the fear that it eliminates,
cause like,
you know how like lifting,
you're not that discipline that you take home two weeks off.
A lot of them when you come back from that two weeks,
like you have that added element of nervousness like,
Dang,
am I going to gas or am I going to get,
you know,
tapped out in front of everybody when you know,
when,
you know,
maybe there is a higher expectation on me or something like that.
Yeah.
No,
I don't have that.
Yeah.
Some part of it though,
for sure.
Uh,
but I would say the number one philosophical lesson,
I guess this is a philosophical lesson is the same thing that I learned from
combat and that's humility in Jujitsu is absolutely one of the most humbling
experiences in the world.
And we've actually,
I got people now that have started Jujitsu cause the podcast and they say,
oh I just did my first Jujitsu class.
Damn,
that was humbling.
It is extremely humbling.
You're going to get beat,
you're never going to know everything.
You're always going to be learning that there's other ways to do things and
somebody that just started can come up with amazing techniques and that's
humbling.
And there's other martial arts that have better moves that you need to pay
attention to.
Like wrestling has better take downs like Samba with the leg locks and catch
wrestling.
Some of those things that are better moves and you need to apply those.
And guess what?
You still need to know how to strike because it can be hard to take people down.
It's new,
didn't know how to,
how to strike,
and you can't be cocky and you can't be overconfident because the bottom line is
in Jujitsu you will get beat
and you will get beat by smaller guys,
by weaker guys,
by older guys,
you're going to get beat and there's somebody that's better than you,
and if you don't like that or if your ego doesn't like that,
then
you got to find a new game to play.
Yeah,
because you need to find a softer game or an easier game because Jujitsu is
honest.
Yeah,
and you escape that
and that's as it should be.
And it's of course this philosophical,
this philosophy is something that I definitely carried over to combat and carry
over to when I talked to businesses and carry over to life.
You can't be over coffee.
You,
you can't be over confident.
You're never going to think you know everything.
You have to respect the enemy.
That's part of humility.
You got to respect your,
if you're not humble,
you don't respect your enemy,
you don't respect your opponent,
you don't respect your competitor.
And if you don't,
that's when you're going to get caught.
So to me,
humility is the most important thing that Jujitsu teaches you.
Yeah.
And it's kind of a can be kind of a not a trick.
I'm gonna call it a trick because Kay,
you gotta you gotta maintain the humility.
Right.
But that humility will be tested if you stick with it.
So,
and I'll tell you a little quick story about that test being bestowed upon me.
It was like a little after I got my purple belt else really,
like I really hit my stride.
I was competing a lot in weaning and,
um,
and you were training with me a lot back.
Yes.
That was,
that was right at that time when I was training with you and you are,
you know what I,
you know,
if,
if there was a,
there was a little bit of mentorship going on.
Mentorship.
Yeah.
That was the exact time.
And,
um,
and I was like,
yeah,
that I started to kind of,
you know,
giving into my own hype,
like,
Oh,
I'm the man,
and not outwardly,
but on the inside and um,
and,
and just fun Ju Ju Jitsu man gets cocky on the inside,
on the inside.
Yeah.
And here's the thing,
a lot of people,
that's how you know it.
In fact,
a little bit of that is good because you get that confidence,
that hunger to even learn more and be better.
Um,
so I had that and then Greg and enrolled with Craig since I w I didn't know him
as good,
but I knew him,
but not as good as I do now.
And last time,
I want to say the last time I rolled with him,
I was a white belt long time ago and he just would destroy me.
So I was like,
Greg,
like,
oh yeah,
hey,
you know,
congratulations to,
you've been winning and stuff like that.
I was like,
Oh yeah.
He's like,
all right.
Yeah,
let's,
let's roll.
So I'm like,
all right,
let me,
shit what,
yeah.
I'm thinking in my mind.
Yeah,
I've been winning here.
Let me go ahead and show you my new stuff.
You know,
it's going to show Greg in my own mind,
and Greg took me like I was a white belt again,
immediately,
the kind of word,
literally nothing.
I did work in everything.
He did work.
He was like,
it's like he did a step one,
step two,
step three,
tap me out.
Still wants them to say tap me out.
And that was the time where I got put from like the top of the mountain in my
own head.
Right to the bottom of the mountain.
Literally to the bottom.
Not to,
not almost at the bottom to the bottom of the mountain.
Yeah,
that's,
it's actually,
it's actually so good when that happens.
And actually it's something I,
I occasionally Jujitsu,
super humbling.
Occasionally you get someone that
is really,
really good and they don't recognize,
they don't come up against people all the time that are,
they don't come up against people very often that are better than them.
Yeah.
Most people in the beginning you have,
you have several years of of being beat down,
but occasionally get somebody that's a great wrestler or maybe they were a judo
player or something,
so they come into the game or they're just super strong or they're just a freak
athlete and so they very quickly,
you don't want a matter of six months to a year,
all of a sudden they're doing really well.
Yeah.
Sometimes those people,
sometimes those people mentally,
they might be good at Jujitsu,
but they,
they don't,
they don't mentally get it and they become really bullies and that's a,
that's,
that's one of the,
it doesn't happen that often,
like I said,
but it does occasionally happen where you get somebody that just is a dominant
force,
they don't get humbled enough and,
and they don't because even if you don't actually get humbled Jujitsu,
normally in the beginning you learn like,
oh,
because one of the things I say to people is,
I'm not,
you know,
because I can tap you.
It doesn't mean that I'm a better human than you.
It just means I trained more Jiu Jitsu than you.
There's,
you know what I mean?
That's all it means.
And that means that someone else was training Jiu Jitsu more than me and they
can beat me.
And that's just what it is.
But sometimes people think that because they can tap somebody out that they're
better than them.
Yeah.
As a human,
yeah.
There is a superiority that's not a good attitude to have.
That's not what you did to,
should be about.
Yeah.
And let's go with a lot of times because they,
and this is just kind of a one way to put it,
they don't pay their dues so to speak.
Right.
You know,
like a normal,
they don't get the humility lesson over and over and over again.
They get it like a few times,
but then they overcome it quickly and it outweighs that outweighs.
Yup.
So you gotta be careful of that.
And so just,
just be,
just be careful that if you're,
if you're a person that's naturally really adept,
that Jujitsu,
make sure you're not getting,
uh,
turning into a bully.
Yeah.
And a lot of times that can block you from learning.
Oh it definitely box cause it's like why would I,
why would I start learning all this Weirdo game?
Like if you're strong wrestler,
like why would I start learning bottom game?
Yeah.
If when I'm killing with all this other stuff because there's someone that's a
better wrestler than you.
Yeah.
That's why we're just knows the combination because a lot of times certain guys
they'll,
they'll know the combo to beat wrestling without having to do wrestling.
Yeah.
Make some guys that they're just like that,
you know?
So part of it Jujitsu.
Okay,
next question.
Have you ever been so dug in on a solution or an opinion that it felt impossible
to admit that you are in fact wrong?
So I actually almost gave up on this question and
because it's been,
I learned this lesson a long time ago that again,
the humility that you get from Jujitsu and from combat and from life is that I
very seldom dig in on something that I'm not a hundred percent sure of.
[inaudible] which means I don't dig in on the locks.
I'm not 100% sure of much.
Right.
Who can be 100% sure of a lot of things and when I do do that,
it's not that hard for me to realize that a wrong stifle my ego,
admit it and change course,
it's not that big of a deal to me.
When I,
like I said,
when I do dig in on a subject or on a decision,
it's because I know
like almost to a 100% certainty that I'm right.
Otherwise I'm going to leave myself a little bit of an out.
I'm not going to just dig in on things that I can't be positive about because
why would I,
why would I do that?
Now when I end up being wrong,
if I do take a stance on something,
it's no big deal.
I'm going to use that as an opportunity to show that I'm humble and show that I
can admit when I'm wrong,
I'm going to take advantage of it.
Good and wrong.
Good.
And you know,
so I would say just keep your options open.
Keep an open mind when you feel yourself or your ego is digging in,
just check yourself and admit that you're wrong and move on.
And one thing I think that happens with people is people think that digging in
and having a strong 100% opinion makes them appear stronger or it makes their
idea appear stronger.
But I don't think so.
I don't,
I'm not saying to be wishy washy on stuff,
I'm just saying no,
I have an open mind because I think that's the ultimate strength.
That's kind of my opinion.
I mean,
the last time I came close to digging in,
I was advising a company and they were going through some rough,
a little bit of a rough patch,
and they started multiple initiatives to try and turn some,
some things around.
And one of the initiatives of all the initiatives,
there was a couple that the CEO wanted done immediately and two of those
initiatives,
when I looked at them,
I thought it,
I thought that they were redundant and so I said,
look,
I wouldn't waste,
I wouldn't do both these initiatives.
Just pick one.
I think this one's the better one,
just do this one and I think it will cover the problem.
And I convinced him and it was pretty easy to convince them because they were
had limited resources at the time and limited assets.
So it wasn't like they had a bunch of stuff to spread around,
but he was pretty set on it.
But I convinced him otherwise and he agreed.
And within a matter of days it started to look like I was wrong and it started
to look like both systems.
We're going to be needed to solve that specific issues.
So I didn't like,
wait,
I didn't say,
oh,
I hope that things go.
I said,
look,
Hey,
I think I was wrong about this.
I think you were right.
Uh,
let's get the other initiative going and let's get this problem covered.
And that's it.
And I'm telling you,
he didn't lose respect for me because I said,
hey,
I'm wrong.
After a few days of watching what the results are and making an early decision,
he actually thought it was awesome and he,
and he knew.
He was like,
Hey,
I wish,
I wish everyone could admit when they were wrong like that he would make
everything around here so much easier.
And I said well that's why I'm here in the first place.
Right.
Is to help with that.
So
just be cautious when you dig in.
You know,
cause when you dig in you're actually,
when you dig in you're taking away your ability to maneuver.
Yeah.
You don't want to do that.
It's good.
So,
so watch out
now
should I read this question because this is a question for Echo Charles.
So that means I get you,
we'll just part of it.
It's two questions actually,
but I put them together cause they're pretty close.
Jocko Willink.
What brought you an echo Charles together.
Can we get the backstory there?
I like the chemistry echo.
Charles,
question for you to answer on Jocko podcast.
What have you learned from Jocko and how has your life changed since this is
Echo's?
First response to a question.
Don't screw it up.
Here we go.
I can heckle you.
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
Which is funny cause that's kind of how what brought us together.
We're a part of what brought us together.
And I think it's good that I answered this part because you probably remember a
lot less of it.
So
[inaudible]
I would say it was oh six.
I see.
I'd seen you like the,
the first,
you know,
whatever within the first year of,
of joining with Dean and oh five.
But I didn't know you didn't talk to you or nothing like that.
I just said heard of you from dean.
Um,
and then in like,
oh six when we moved over to the boxing club,
I rolled with you one time.
I was still a white belt and uh,
so that could have been still owe five,
I don't know.
And then,
you know,
you beat me up and you,
you kind of,
you were just more like a,
this stoic guy basically.
I would imagine the same guy that people interpret you to be from the outside,
you know,
Kinda like,
not intense,
but just real like oil,
just real matter of fact,
you know?
Um,
so you beat me up or whatever.
And then I was,
so I,
since I had already heard of you,
you were deans black belt and you know,
all this stuff that I was like,
yeah,
that's about right.
You know,
he's,
you know,
good,
you just do whatever beat me up.
But that wasn't really saying much cause everyone was beating me up and then,
um,
time went on.
I didn't see you for awhile.
And then,
um,
when I started to kind of get golf,
I was trained with Brent.
Brent.
Yeah.
I was training with him and then with Ileus a little bit and then you'd come
back,
I was competing and then you are just around for whatever reason.
Um,
and then yeah,
I just started training with and think that's when we opened victory.
Right?
Yes.
There's around the same time.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
And then,
um,
yeah,
what was funny is that you never came off.
Like once they knew you,
like immediately you never came off as this super intense person.
Like it was more like you were just sarcastic,
like,
well,
you know,
like any other,
uh,
any other of my friends.
But
you could still always tell that there was something behind the scenes,
you know,
Darrel Rogan said like he's seen you and he was like,
there's one thing to note with this guy,
you know,
he's like,
he's kind of got that same feeling,
but you were always just like,
oh yeah,
this real matter of fact,
but fun,
funny like kind of person or whatever.
Like,
but when I say matter of fact,
I mean like,
um,
like that one,
this one tournament when,
uh,
it was kind of later where I lost two Sean Roberts and he got me with a Gogo
Plata and you know,
when you lose in Jujitsu,
and that was the first time I lost in since I went advanced,
you know,
cause I was doing a lot of Nogi I had never lost and Sean Roberts gives me with
a Google Plata.
So instead of you saying,
Hey,
you know,
it's okay or nothing like that,
you send me a text,
you're sitting across the arena,
you're right there.
You send me a text,
hey,
you got caught with a Gogo that's got a stick.
This is a tournament.
It's not a practice,
you can say that.
I was like,
ah,
whatever.
But I think that,
um,
that,
you know,
training together and just kind of getting,
you,
you kind of had that thing that you could say that kind of stuff because really
it's not that serious,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't think,
I don't think there's a,
there's not many people who could have conveyed that though,
you know,
it,
um,
I think it had to come from you anyway.
So yeah,
that's kind of how we met.
And then,
um,
kind of after a while,
how did the idea of a podcast come up?
Cause we kind of talked about it
that a little bit before,
I forget the formation,
but it was in my mind when I went on Joe Rogan's,
I think we had talked about,
hey,
you know,
we should do something.
I think you said to me like,
Hey,
you should do it.
And so when I went on Joe Rogan's and he said,
you should do a podcast.
I think what Tim Ferriss said,
hey,
you should do a podcast.
And then I kind of be you being a techie sound guy,
video guy.
I just said,
hey,
do you know how to make a podcast?
That's right.
I just said,
hey,
how do you knew how to make a podcast?
So I need to make one.
Yeah.
Cause everything to be is just a total caveman.
Right.
How do you do I need a tape recorder?
What do I need?
You know,
that's what my,
and so then you said,
yeah,
I know,
I know how to do that.
I could make that happen.
And then you said it'd be cool instead of just you sitting there talking if you
had someone to talk to.
And I said,
yeah,
you're right.
That would be cool.
And then you'd said it'd be cool if it was me.
Well My,
my selling point was that strange.
If it's just you right
sitting there,
you know,
it's,
it's more strange and it's better if you have someone to kind of bounce things
off of.
I suppose just someone who can kind of be like,
oh I'm just an everyday guy.
Like,
so I can like ask questions to kind of reiterate the point in which to someone
who might not get it.
Yeah.
I had it all thought out,
you know,
in my mind I did anyway.
Um,
but yeah,
then yeah,
obviously Joe Rogan was kind of the tipping point when he suggested it.
Yeah.
No,
that was good.
Great insight from Joe Rogan and I'm glad he did.
And I'm glad you did it.
I'm,
Oh God,
we did make this podcast happen.
So to answer the question,
what have I learned?
Um,
and this is interesting cause I asked myself this exact same question like,
like a week ago because I am literally a different person now in ways that kind
of are kind of surprising in a way.
So I took the first thing that's Kinda,
kinda not that surprising,
but um,
it's,
it's very prevalent is when people blame.
When I see people blaming other people or blaming me or I feel the compulsion to
blame someone else,
it stands out like a sore thumb.
Almost.
Like if,
if I'm feeling that and it like,
almost like if I want to say something to,
to indicate that I'm going to blame somebody or something,
it's almost like a red flag.
Like I'm not allowed to do that in my own mind.
It's like this hard and fast rule.
And like I said,
they just stand out like a sore thumb everywhere though on TV,
you know,
the guy,
not even my conversation.
Oh,
I see what you're doing right there.
You know?
So it's like,
it's like your whole way of life in that regard is just shifted extreme
ownership and the awareness of that,
seeing it in other people or lack of it and other people definitely stands out
like crazy once you start thinking about it.
Yeah.
And I have the luxury of being around you talking about these things,
talking about examples of it every week,
right?
So throughout the week I'm like,
I can't even help but notice it,
you know,
and it's Friday.
It helps men because it applies to everyone who'd been everything.
Like most relationships are going to apply these principles,
you know,
if you're involved in them.
Um,
so yeah,
it's all automatic now.
So,
so when it comes to ownership and really blaming myself,
if anyone and focusing on my responsibility in any scenario,
whatever it comes automatic now I would say is a huge step.
I mean,
whether I make the right choices,
that's always going to be a work in progress I think.
But as far as that attitude,
it's automatic.
No,
that's awesome.
And then,
um,
in regards to,
okay,
so I've always been into working out and so me not feeling like working out is,
I've always felt like working out.
So
as far as not feeling like it,
that wasn't really a factor.
But in a bunch of other things in life it was a factor.
And so,
and so you're saying we not feeling like doing Y or z?
Yeah.
Like,
oh,
I got to,
I got to go to the post office today and that's on the low end.
And then,
or the other one is,
I dunno,
I gotta I dunno,
something more important.
Right.
But maybe I'll wait,
I'll wait until really the last minute or you know,
procrastination type stuff.
So you're getting into the here and now.
Yeah.
And not feeling like it.
That means absolutely,
you know,
absolutely nothing.
It's something needs to be done and I don't feel like it.
And you know how like you have,
you have the certain ideas already and then other ideas are introduced and then
those ideas kind of mingle with your existing ideas and they formulate this
whole new course of action.
Right.
So the not feeling like it is no excuse.
That idea came in and so now I'm like,
it morphed into this thing like me not feeling like it who gets what I'm going
to do,
I'm going to do it right.
Also,
it's almost like this personal challenge now you know?
And Man,
as far as results go,
man,
you get everything done.
I hit,
eats up so much stuff done and it's not so probably compared to you,
it's nothing.
But I get stuff done like so many things done during the day that I had never
thought that I could do that many things in a day.
That's awesome.
All,
I was always looking for maybe a rest or a nap or something like that.
But now every once in a while I'll be challenging myself to do as many things as
I can.
It'd be like solid and on top of that.
And you're the one who said this was,
um,
one time,
one of the things,
you were kind of tired and you were like,
you know what?
But I liked this.
I liked just grinding and grinding and grinding.
And then at the end of the day when I go home,
go to bed where my head just crashes into the pill.
I liked that.
And I was like,
yeah,
that sounds nice.
You know?
So when I approach things like that now,
and also I think of all the good things that have been done,
great things and just good things,
whatever,
if these people didn't do it because they didn't feel like it,
I think these things wouldn't have got done,
you know?
So if you've got stuff to do,
you do it whether you feel like it or not.
That's what I have for myself now.
Um,
and the last thing
is,
I kind of knew this,
but man,
it's so clear now that you can get certain messages and information and tips and
tactics and stuff from,
from people or the internet or books or whatever.
But if you're not ready to accept them,
you just won't accept them.
Or they'll just go in one ear and out the other.
And a lot of times that has to do with Hussein it.
So
if like,
I don't know your neighbor some goof off,
he's drinking a beer,
smoking a cigarette,
he's like,
Hey,
guess what?
You know,
you should do this.
And it's the,
it can be this great advice,
but you can be like,
I'm not going to listen to you.
I'm not even gonna listen to you.
I'm not even get past that part.
The fact that you're the one that's saying this already walked me off from what
you have to say.
And that's natural I think.
But a lot of these things,
like you're reading these old books that have these messages that you've been
saying,
so it's not new stuff.
And a lot of stuff,
like I heard that take responsibility for your actions.
Yeah.
How's that?
That's not new.
If I bust out,
hey,
you guy had on the street,
take responsibility for your actions.
If something comes up,
I'm just saying he'd be like,
yeah,
that's nothing new.
It wouldn't stand out.
But for some reason when you're saying it,
it gets you think,
yeah,
let me take responsibility.
You know,
so that,
so yeah.
It say when it comes to listening to you,
this podcast,
all the,
you know,
the,
the answers that you have for these questions and any questions I even have,
it seems like it comes and I process it way more readily than,
you know,
memes on Facebook or wherever,
you know.
So,
yeah.
That's awesome.
Pretty true.
See,
that's really cool.
That's,
that's great to hear.
And I've,
I mean,
I've definitely seen a transition in everything you're doing.
everything you're doing is spot on and that's legit.
It's legit to see.
It's legit to see someone moving towards their potential as a human.
Yeah.
That's awesome to see.
And another thing that kind of a,
I came to as not a conclusion but it,
which is a result,
it's not a direct,
like you didn't tell me this,
but this is what all my existing thoughts mixed with all your input kind of
arrived at.
One of the things is that it's up to you.
It's up to me what I spend my time doing totally up to me and it's up to me what
I feel my head filled my head with.
So you know,
like I used to have these shows that I love to,
I love the watch Hawaii five o and shark tank and that's Kinda it.
I don't really watch that much TV,
but those two
that's maybe you know,
two hours or so that I could be reading something that's going to help me
through the rest of my life or getting better at something that's going to help
my,
you know,
relationships or career or something like that.
And I use that example because that seems pretty,
pretty like not in consequence in consequential because it's only two shows.
It's not like I spend 10 hours a day watching TV.
It's just do shows who cares.
No harm in that.
Right.
But that's up to me.
I'm not missing out by missing Hawaii,
not missing out.
That's not going to affect my life in any negative way in the future at all.
I didn't want to affect my life in any way actually.
But if I read something useful,
educate myself in,
you know,
whatever arena that's going to improve my interests or my,
or my relationship or something like that,
that will,
that will help me.
Yeah.
No,
I,
that's one of the things I've noticed.
And I'd show up,
show up at the studio and you take all,
I was reading this book today about,
you know,
how we could get this to sound better.
And I read this thing about,
you know,
you're coming back to me with all this information and it was something that
just transitioned in your brain where you said,
you know what,
I could be watching TV in wasting my mind or I could be applying myself and
learning.
Yeah.
And that's,
that makes a huge difference rather as well.
One of the things I read actually,
um,
and I read it on,
I want to say Wikipedia,
this specific thing,
but there's this,
um,
this automatic way of thinking and uh,
it's called hyperbolic discounting,
right?
And all that,
it,
all that means is you choose immediate payoffs versus,
and I kind of mentioned this before,
you choose immediate payoffs versus longterm pass,
right?
And it's there for a reason.
Survival mechanism and all these ways,
but it's old.
It exists for an,
you know,
an environment that's not current.
So if you can basically a,
be aware of that and combat that were,
don't do the immediate payoff things.
So just take,
take what you're about to do,
evaluate it.
Is this going to help me other than the pleasure that I think,
whether that in regards to food,
drinking,
TV shows,
like if you watch reality TV,
check yourself on down and ask yourself,
is this going to help me in the future?
And typically the answer for those types of things are going to be no.
And then consider an alternative that you can do.
And a lot of the stuff can be pleasurable that will help you in the future and
it's totally up to you.
It's totally up to you.
Why not make the good choice.
Yeah,
and the pay off.
Not only is it bigger,
it lasts longer.
Yeah,
the immediate payoff is gone.
It's just a memory.
Awesome.
That's awesome to hear.
And
it actually,
we got that next comment here is sort of the same vein it's coming from and we
get a bunch of emails,
but I just thought this one was,
was interesting to hear someone kind of talking about their transition here.
She says,
I'm one of many,
many people who live their lives as they think they should and end up mid
forties lost chubby and depressed.
I definitely don't hear a worship you,
but I'm truly grateful for your online presence.
I now get up at 5:00 AM daily and I screen grabbed my phone every morning as the
alarm goes off and post that shot with another shop from my walk.
A few minutes in.
I walked for an hour daily and it started stretching daily for an hour,
but this doesn't stop there.
I now have a bunch of friends who are getting up early and going for a walk or
going to the gym,
getting after it has you say we are all noticing an improvement in our lives so
we might not be military or police.
We are not planning on becoming Jujitsu champions at this stage.
We are just people who lost themselves,
lost their way,
who are finding their way back in part thanks to you.
I credit you at least twice a week and tell people to find you on Twitter.
I had to write here because there's no way I could fit this into 140 characters
and thanks to Tim and Joe for having you on their shows.
That's where I found you have a great day.
So it really cool.
You know?
Really cool to hear that.
Really great to get that feedback and
you know,
this is what I like about it.
Well,
first of all,
if you don't,
I think people were spreading the words and it's really good to hear that
feedback.
It fires me up to hear the feedback.
And when people say,
when people say,
I motivate them,
I'm always like,
you motivate me.
You know that it motivates me that you're out there getting up at 5:00 AM and,
and turning your life around.
I think that's awesome.
And also what I,
what I liked about this was they pointed out that this isn't just military or
police or Jujitsu players.
It's for pretty much anybody in any station in life,
in any job,
any age,
man or woman,
any country.
And as a matter of fact,
I was in England and my wife's from England and when I was in England,
I went and saw one of my wife's friends who I'm friends with the husband and you
know,
here's this woman
who's,
I don't know,
40 something years old,
she's lives in England,
she's got three kids.
She's like,
couldn't be any further detached from me in my life.
And when I was,
I was hanging out with her husband in London before we went to their house and
he said,
when we got on the train to go to his house,
listen,
you got to be ready.
And I'm like,
for what?
And he says,
my wife loves your podcast.
And I said,
really?
And he said,
no,
I'm serious.
She loves your podcast and we have dinner night.
She's going to ask you questions all night long.
She's been asking me the questions that she was going to ask you.
And so I showed up and seriously,
it was great.
She was asking me all these detailed questions about everything.
And it was really cool because I realized that this,
I mean this,
like I said,
this person doesn't do Jujitsu,
doesn't,
you know,
doesn't do anything that I do nothing.
And yet she was,
I had all these lessons learned and all of these things she had taken away and
it was awesome to see that.
And it was interesting to,
because that's how I was talking to her.
It was on a Friday or a Saturday.
And as I'm talking to her,
she had listened to the latest podcast on the day before.
And so she was saying to me,
you know,
well yesterday you said this,
and yesterday you said that.
And so in her mind,
I was talking to her yesterday,
I was talking to her yesterday and that's when I kind of realized that how
impactful it is,
what we talked about,
where you know,
where the words,
the podcast wars are going directly into your brain.
And I've had a bunch of people say,
you know,
Oh,
when you're talking,
oh you were telling the story,
I wanted you to talk about this story.
You know,
if these are friends of mine.
And so,
so I think that's,
that's really cool.
And um,
I think that's why a lot of people are getting into the game and enjoying it.
And you just said it and I,
I say it all the time.
There's nothing new here and we're not giving out any groundbreaking techniques
and there's no miracle drug and there's no three minute exercise that's going to
change your life.
I'm not selling this self help reach your potential through this magical
mystery.
I'm telling people what they already know and we're talking about things that
people know to be right in their own heads,
like discipline and hard work and consistency.
Those are the things and we all know those things,
but
okay.
To everybody that's,
that's kind of known these things for a while,
but they've recently started to get after it.
Good on you.
Yeah.
And get on that path.
It feeling,
stay on that path.
That's what I'm talking about.
Very cool.
I feel like,
um,
like just like how you were saying like we,
we a lot of this,
we already knew,
we already know about state discipline,
we already know about all this stuff or whatever.
But coming from you it helps.
And then on top of that new than an added an element that I'm,
that I'm kind of really starting to really understand and feel is that,
you know,
how like you on Twitter,
like you engage,
you know,
you like if someone asks you a questions,
it seems like you're engaging them a lot more so than if somebody asked me the
question,
I'm going to answer the question.
Yeah.
I'm not rude,
which is good.
I tried to for sure.
Um,
I would imagine you'd be,
you know,
have way more than me,
but um,
kind of as a result of everything,
I feel like we're all kind of doing this together.
You know,
you know how the guys done in Australia,
they'll post all that.
You know,
a lot of people,
eh,
everyone they're posting their,
you know,
4:30 AM wake up time to do this.
Everyone.
Yeah.
Cause that's what you did.
Now guess what?
We're all doing it.
Yeah.
You know,
we're all doing it.
You're responding,
they're responding to you,
you're responding to them.
We're reading questions from them.
Yeah.
Kind of weird.
Like these are other people.
Yeah.
In through this weird interweb you're actually asking questions from some
unknown partner.
We're having a conversation basically.
Yeah.
It's kind of delayed,
but yeah,
that's exactly what's going on.
So example,
I should've just grabbed my phone and saw that,
I forget the guy's name,
but he was like,
hey,
echo Sunday workout Sunday.
This was like early this morning,
or maybe late last night,
whatever.
Sunday out.
Give me one.
I need a Sunday workout.
So I was like,
oh,
okay.
So I gave him the workout.
It was basically,
um,
uh,
two rounds,
five sets of,
um,
cleaning clean and press fights,
five reps clean and press five times,
and then five burpees.
That's one set.
Do five sets,
45 seconds,
rest in between rest for two minutes in the new five more,
45 seconds rest.
That's it.
Use 135 pounds.
I only said 135 pounds because that's what,
that's the exact thing I do after I lift.
And that's like,
to me,
that's the hard lifting side,
that heart.
But that part's kind of hard to me.
The metcon,
the metcon.
Yeah.
So I'm like,
but I don't know,
maybe I don't know if I'm in good shape or not.
Yeah.
As far as that goes.
So I think I say you do it and use that weight.
But the thing,
if he's smaller for,
I don't know how big he is,
we're just talking on Twitter,
you know?
So you know that put the weight didn't really matter.
It doesn't,
he scaled it properly.
Well,
he said later on he was like,
Dang,
that allows pain.
But I feel great.
I was like solid.
He said,
hey,
but I adjusted the weight.
Okay.
So I'm saying,
okay,
you know,
that makes sense.
But my,
my two reasons why I'm into that is because I wanted that interaction.
Like,
Hey,
do my workout.
You know,
and what I'm going to do,
and I thought of this earlier this morning where,
um,
or earlier today I'm going to send them back.
So you give me a workout,
oh nice.
And I'm going to do it and make it something at least close to what you do or
something you do.
And I'll give you an evaluation.
Right.
You know?
So hopefully I can get some variety and it will help that interaction.
I think that's dope.
Yeah.
Like how he actually went and did it.
I was like,
heck yeah,
let's do that.
Some barn in Iowa or some,
yeah,
he was awesome.
Good deal.
Last question.
There must be some aspect of the tootsie situation that I don't understand.
Even if I'm on the losing side of a fight,
I still want to go down swinging.
I could tell how much this affected Jocko.
It would suck to be so close to such an unjust fight and not be able to do
anything about it.
Yes,
it is hard to look at that situation and really understand it and it's horrible.
Look back at it now
and know that we didn't do anything about it,
but,
but what can we do with it?
How can we apply this to everyday life?
Because I agree with you.
You gotta go down swinging.
Yeah.
And I'll tell you this.
If you,
if you fight with all you've got,
okay.
More often than not,
you won't go down at all.
Okay.
You win.
But you gotta make that attitude part of your everyday life,
the extra rep,
the extra mile,
the extra round,
the right choices
to make yourself stronger mentally and physically
stand and fight.
Fight against weakness and against fear.
Okay.
They're fighting against time and decay.
Fight back,
go down,
swinging.
Give everyday everything you've got.
Yeah.
And when can,
when you face a challenge,
even something where you don't believe you can win.
Okay.
Maybe to situation where you cannot win,
but if you can't win,
remember this,
you have nothing to lose.
So stand up and go forward and go out in a blaze of glory fighting with
everything you've got.
Every ounce of energy,
every beat is sweat and every drop of blood
to your last breath.
And then,
and only then
you can stand down
and you can put down your sword and you can put down your shield
and rest
in peace.
I think that's all I've got for tonight.
So thanks all you troopers out there tuning in and listening.
And thanks for rob membering.
And you know we started this off tonight
with a statement of remembrance of some fallen warriors.
So thanks for remembering them,
remembering the past,
remembering war and the horror and the glory and the heroes makes remembering
that.
And thanks for learning from them.
Thanks for connecting with us through the interwebs.
You guys out there are opening my mind with the books that you're sending me,
the articles that you're sending me,
that video is,
you're sending me that connections you're making,
you're making us smarter.
So thank you.
And of course,
thanks for supporting the podcast,
listening,
downloading,
subscribing,
reviewing,
write reviews.
Get on iTunes and rights and reviews if you want,
if you feel like it.
Yeah.
And then the other forms of support we got
on it,
of course on it.com/jocko get 10% off.
Boom.
Get you some warrior bars.
That's right.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we were birds is the for sure.
Um,
and some Alpha brain of course,
when you read anyway,
yeah.
Or yeah,
or click or go to Jocko,
podcast.com and before you shop in Amazon,
click on the Amazon link into your shop and that,
that's cool.
Um,
donate if you want.
We got that now.
And,
uh,
and yeah,
if you like the t shirts and
okay.
Coffee Mugs,
bumper stickers that uh,
we got to Jocko store to gay,
get some of those solid.
Also if you want to add to the conversation when you're not listening to the
podcast Jocko is that Jocko Willink.
Oh,
Twitter,
Twitter
at Jocko Willink,
Jocko Willink and I met at Echo Charles ng made the Facebook too,
which has not been utilized as much yet.
Right.
And I've been slowly checking them.
Um,
all right,
check them.
We pulled questions from him.
Oh,
okay,
good.
Good.
Okay.
Yeah,
so facebook.com/jocko podcast and I think slowly we're going to transition to
getting the questions from there.
Oh yeah.
Everywhere.
Probably.
Really good question.
It's a good question.
The long questions.
I mean,
yeah,
it's hard.
Good spot.
Don't take pictures of long questions and post them cause I copy and paste them
into a document.
All right,
sir.
Yeah.
Folks out there that took pictures of questions and I twittered you back and
said,
hey,
write that.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Cool.
Yeah,
there it is.
Boom.
You,
and if you,
uh,
if you're interested in the book,
Leif Babin and I wrote extreme ownership.
It's all these basic principles we talk about all the time.
You can get it hardcover kindle,
or you get an audio book,
which the Audio Book is myself and life reading it.
So,
or any books that you've covered on any of these podcasts,
Jocko,
store.com by the way,
it's on the top menu.
You Click on that,
that books,
and it'll show the description and what podcast it was on,
et Cetera,
and you can buy them from there.
Awesome.
So finally and most importantly to everybody out there,
you sitting there with your headphones on listening.
Thank you.
Thanks for deciding that you are going to hold the line,
that you're going to fight through the discomfort and the weakness and the pain,
and you're going to get up
and get after it,
right?
So until next time,
okay,
this is Jocko and echo
out.